I'll start with reading the script
smiling you're trimming on the recording
is yes we're recording very good
as chair of the house Edna committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 First Look to
executive order 2020 before this public
body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any Bill referred to the Committees
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in the meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting provides
with house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email hcs.leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
all votes that are taking this meeting
shall be done by roll call
we'll start by taking a roll call
attendance and when each member states
they're present please also State there
if anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to know law
and in order to to vote if we are voting
on an event
any bill it needs to be by video so we
can see your face thank you
foreign
I am here and I am home in Rochester my
wife is in the house
representative bowley
here at home and my wife is in the other
room
representative Rhoda
I am home in my office
alone
representative Judy
I am home my wife she's in your room
[Music]
representative murder is here
representative legis is here I'll have
you sign representative McGuire is here
I'll have you sign representative
O'Brien
I am present and I'm here in Nashua and
Home Alone
representative Pearson representative
Pearson is in the room oh I'm sorry
representative uh Roy
uh representative Roy here I'm replacing
here are you replacing Roy yes
representative Roy is not here
personally bad
I'm here at home the family is around
zooming I've been upgraded to the living
room
our representative senator nastasso
I'm here uh alone in range
representative Schmidt
representative Schmidt I see you on you
mute yourself please
are you yeah I'm sorry I didn't mute
myself so I didn't unmute myself
and we see I'm apparently unmuted can
you hear me yeah representative show it
yes
yes I'm present at my home alone
representative Schultz
presents at my home in Concord and my
husband Gene Taylor will be in and out
of the room and I'm here the clerk is
here representative yakubovic
present at home alone in the room
it's really bad
uh Madam chairman we have a full house
thank you
all right
on house
bill
relative using Atlanta Standard time I
call Representative yukelo the prime
sponsor
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee
and uh thank you for accepting my
testimony in favor of my bill uh moving
us to the Atlantic time zone and off of
uh daylight savings time
this bill may look very familiar as it
is the same bill that was
um passed from this committee a couple
of years ago
and it is it is uh back again so in in
California and Florida they have passed
uh measures around uh daylight savings
times in an attempt to go to Daylight
Savings time all year round however that
would require an act of Congress
which
um efforts are moving towards that but
it doesn't seem to be
um forthcoming
and so this proposal would make that
same move without the need for an act of
Congress
um in 2017 Massachusetts formed a
special commission to study the costs
and benefits of this change and they
actually came up with the idea of moving
to the well they kind of sanctioned the
idea of moving
um
as a group to the Atlantic time zone
instead of
um waiting for for Congress to allow
Ed
allowing for or waiting for the for
Congress to allow that move
um they've the commission found that
there was an increase in economic growth
and productivity while reducing
on-the-job injuries traffic fatalities
heart attacks energy costs Greenhouse
emissions
um
a lot of these benefits come from just
not switching
twice a year
however
since we are
um honest
based on our longitude
uh the the
Eastern time zone is very wide time zone
it covers about
um one hour and a half to one hour and
45 minutes of of time uh via the Sun and
so it was
suggested that at least part of the
eastern part of the Eastern Time Zone
moved to
uh
this this Atlantic time zone while
leaving the western part of the the uh
the eastern time current Eastern Time
Zone in their uh
current time
so that uh it would more reflect what
the sun is actually doing uh
another recommendation which
which is uh kind of goes in tandem with
this but is not something that should be
uh addressed uh via a statute is a
recommendation for schools to not start
before 8 30 a.m this goes to the
suggestion that children need that their
their sleep and also with this when this
um
this passes you don't want to have uh
kids going to school in the dark
um so with this result
um well currently eastern time zones
States
in the uh very far east part of that
time zone when they fall fall back in
the winter they have sunsets around 5 to
5 30 P.M
and this can uh cause issues in the
evening commute in the dark which
increases collisions with pedestrians
and Wildlife and
um
so this this change would only affect
those winter months we would only be
uh at a different time zone than the the
rest of the Eastern time zone four
months of the year as long as they kept
their daylight savings time
and so
one of the the hurdles
that have come up with this is
um
pushed back by
uh
the broadcasters Association
um
because of the
the
complexities of trying to
create more ad uh
options and selling ad space
and so
the way that it was trying that that the
Commission in Massachusetts tried to
address this issue was to go as a block
and that's why this bill is
contingent on kind of our our region of
Massachusetts and
um Maine but if it uh if we came to an
agreement with the uh
the broadcasters Association that more
States would be needed to be
economically feasible for them that
would be considered absolutely
um
and so with that uh I would like to
thank you for for hearing my testimony
and there there is an expert hopefully
um let me just
make sure yeah
um an expert that is uh I welcome to uh
talk about it this issue in more detail
his name is Scott Yates if you would be
able to um
to to talk to the more more uh intricate
details of the studies and stuff like
that but I would be happy to um
entertain like more general questions if
the committee has such thank you
thank you representative
um just looking through the
latter part of the bill the 24-25 area
line you reference made in Massachusetts
it's my understanding that Rhode Island
has also entered into a metoo clause
in the event that Boston chooses to go
to the Atlantic time zone as well am I
correct in that
so thank you for the question
um yes so this kind of
um a bunch of states have
um similar bills with similar
contingencies and so kind of like main
uh it currently doesn't have a bill but
if Maine had one before they were
contingent on New Hampshire and New
Hampshire was contingent on
Massachusetts and Rhode Island is
contingent on Connecticut
and Connecticut is contingent on
Massachusetts and and uh
and uh New York now and so it kind of
just creates a kind of rolling effect of
we need a bigger and bigger block
um before it actually goes into effect
but once it happens pretty much the
whole region is going to go at the same
time and
um so for those reasons that's why I
would be more I would be open to
um larger blocks per pose potentially by
a broadcasters Association so thank you
for the question
um
is Connecticut actually considering uh
changing because I wouldn't expect them
to move from different time zone to New
York City given the number of people in
Connecticut that uh
thank you for the question they actually
have two bills
uh this time uh this session for that
exact uh this exact language and they
are contingent on New York last time uh
they had a bill that wasn't contingent
on New York and they added that
contingency so the bill currently in uh
Connecticut well both of the bills are
contingent on New York so if that bill
passes and New York is also considering
the same it the same uh Bill and their
contingent on New Jersey and so it's
it's a cascading effect
yes thank you I I think we should uh
just keep it with Massachusetts in Maine
and let New York deal with its own
problems
all right uh
I
other questions
see uh Madam chair if I may fine yes
please representative yes thank you
madam chair uh thank you representative
for taking the question uh we all kind
of live through the Y2K and nothing
really happened but I would like you to
speak about the economic impact uh with
computers and everything else when you
uh purchase new electronic equipment it
has you designate which type of time
zone that you're in and uh would that
affect any type of uh uh problems with
the electronic devices that could have
an economical impact on the economy that
you anticipate with this
thank you for the question
um so as you alluded to there is just a
switch that that um computers have to
designate which time zone that you're in
it automatically
um is
going to go forward correct from that
time on once you select that time zone
and so
it would be a one-time cost up front I
guess and then however the in the uh
special commission report they found
that it was the benefits were greatly
outweighed the cost because it uh they
found that people are much more likely
to go shopping after work if it's still
light and so uh there would just be an
increased economic uh incentive during
the winter months in in New Hampshire
and in this region and so those would
greatly outweigh the one-time costs of
switching to a different time zone on
your computer so thank you for the
question thank you representative
representative
thank you madam chair
if this bill was enacted in
Massachusetts and Maine went along what
time would it be now
it would be
9 9 18.
follow-up follow-up thank you
what other states
have that are outside of New England
have this
regulation
what what excuse me what do you mean by
regulation well this I'm sorry are not
are not using this time zone now let's
say about our mother States on Atlantic
time at the moment it's uh parts of
Canada are yeah okay yeah
thank you for the question currently
um the only place in New in uh
in uh the United States that that uh
does not exha that would be on the same
time zone currently
is
um
Puerto Rico that I know of
but there may be there may be others
other
um districts that
that would be covered under this but uh
they're as far as other states that are
considering this option there is a lot
of them and
um Scott Yates may be able to
more fully address how many people are
considering this option versus
considering the option of moving to
Daylight Savings time all year round and
waiting for congress versus other other
options that are proposed to address the
issue of the time switching
thank you for the question
it's bowling
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
uh the bill states that within 180 days
of similar actions between Maine and
Massachusetts that the governor shall
petition the United States Secretary of
Transportation to move to the Atlantic
time zone
is he uh is he secretary
obliged to
go along with this or can he deny it
so it's a shell so it would be required
that he submit the application uh the
there would be hearings on the cost
benefits and people would testify to
um the
the Secretary of Transportation it
wouldn't be uh we wouldn't be going to
the Secretary of State in New Hampshire
for another
um discussion on whether or not he
should apply if the legislature tells
them to apply then he would apply
follow up follow up
but the U.S Secretary of Transportation
could deny this petition correct
yes thank you for the question
um yes it's potent if it was
unreasonable
um you know there's there's
um things that they might consider
there's strong evidence that shows that
um that there is good reason to and so
it's unlikely that they would would deny
it but it's possible yes absolutely
thank you
representative fellows
hi can you hear me yes no problems
thanks and I'm
coming at from two angles
um representative Ocala isn't it correct
that the Department of Transportation
has very specific standards about how
they would
um decide on making a time zone change
and doesn't it deal primarily with
transportation
thank you for the question
they would consider a wide range of
things but yes obviously it goes with
their name that their main concern is
transportation absolutely
and follow-up please follow up
[Music]
uh the other issue is
um I I read the report from the main
study commission and that was in 2017
and they have
um yet to enact anything in Maine I'm
wondering if you can give us some
history on this proposal to take change
time zones my understanding has been
going on for a number of years in
multiple States and the U.S Department
of Transport Commerce or whoever makes
that decision has yet to approve any of
those time zone changes
that's the end of my question thanks
thank you for the question so there
hasn't been any requests to the um
uh Secretary of Transportation to switch
so there would be no denying or
accepting
um at this state this idea of switching
to Atlantic time zone is relatively new
the the previous efforts were to just
accept daylight savings time all year
around
and wait for the con for Congress to
allow that and so but uh I've only been
um obviously I've only been in the
legislature this is my second term and
so
um Scott Yates would be able to to uh
follow up more with the history and all
the different states many states propose
it
um you know Maine right now is is
suggesting to create their own study
and I talked with the representative
there and they're talking about
potentially just uh putting in a bill to
go with no contingencies no no other
state contingencies but we'll find out
what their their study finds if they end
up passing that legislation so
it's there are many there are many
solutions being being floated but I
don't I don't uh agree that that the
state uh
of TR the Secretary of Transportation
has denied any requests for this this
change because I don't believe it is
um has passed and been
uh requested of them to to change that
so thank you for the question
thank you representative Keller
uh call Representative Oregon
unmuted and he can even see me it's a
good thing I put on a tie for this so my
name is Timothy Horrigan I'm
I'm representing Stratford County's
District Six which is the towns of
Durham and Madbury and I actually back
in 2011 I sponsored the bill that
created the that made the current
statute about daylight savings time and
I was just uh making the definition of
state laws the same as that in federal
law which uh which was something that
could have caused some confusion but it
didn't but it could have so um we
mentioned uh
I mentioned from Durham I was actually
born in South Bend Indiana the hometown
of the current uh Secretary of
Transportation Buddha judge in fact he
lives in uh the same neighborhood where
I spent part of my childhood except I'm
slightly older as you can tell by the
color of my hair
and um
this reason the Department of
Transportation is in charge of time
zones is because this was originally
became necessary when we built the
railroad Network so it caused huge
um
where that people cities were just
operating on them on you know solar time
by where the sun is but um once we had
railroads going we needed to get
everybody in sync and so that's why they
have the time zones they're not
perfectly aligned with longitude it is
true that we're here in New Hampshire
we're about to north of Puerto Rico
which is on the Atlantic Standard Time
and uh
that would probably cause some confusion
so one of the political issues probably
we should wait on this before we make
this change to see if Puerto Rico
becomes a state which seems to be more
probable now than it has in the past
although that like daylight savings time
has been kicked around for years so get
back to South Bend it has to be in the
Northwestern corner of the state near
Chicago and that part of Indiana is
along
history confusion of a controversy and
confusion over daylight savings time in
fact I have two birthdays because of
that because like my mother
uh South Bend I think was operating on
um representative yes so anyway get back
to the point in the hand um
it's an arbitrary thing I've gone
um
Cameron arbitring what we call these
time zones where we draw the lines in
the map but I think it's uh
simplest thing to do is keep with the
current practice even though
switching it's not an ideal thing
switching time zones uh twice a year and
it does cause some problems but I think
it would cause even more problems if we
uh went on a time zone that normally
which now is used only in Puerto Rico
the Virgin Islands so I would say uh
I would say even though there's a lot of
a larger calories a lot you'll create
less confusion to keep things where they
are and um so that is to
also a simpler way if we do want to be
in the same time zone year round with
Maine Massachusetts or whatever Rhode
Island whatever States want to be it
tell us in terms of the label we put on
it
would probably just be easier to go to
Daylight Savings Time year round just
because um
there are some people who don't go to
Canada or Puerto Rico very much you
don't really know what Atlantic Standard
time is so eastern daylight time is the
same time zone as uh as a Atlantic
Standard time so that would be simple
solution even though it does require an
act of Congress that would probably be
simpler than you know what we have
you know 90. questions
well thank you
representative Judy you have a question
yes Madam chair
you have a question
absolutely
looks like he's muted yes you're muted
representative Judy
okay what about now that's better thank
you please ask your question yes
um Madame chair please could you please
reminding me
we have a similar Bill uh a couple years
ago or two years ago uh what is the
difference between those two please
okay
yeah I just say this is a perennial
issue it's it's uh it was not new
um when I worked on the way back 10
years ago
um and uh it's been kicking around for a
while and maybe someday we'll pass a
bill maybe not you know as Revenue
correctly point out it depends on a lot
of other what happens in other states
and federally and so forth it's like
it's a perennial build so that's why so
every two years or so um it comes up
again so here it is so
thank you representative Allegro yes
thank you for taking my question I I
thought I understand this but something
that was just said confused me a little
bit and I just want to make sure I'm 100
clear
the idea was that we're uh we might be
switching to a system used only in
Puerto Rico and Eastern Canada
my understanding is that if this is
enacted it will be only when a chunk of
the Eastern yeah
uh Seaboard yes okay thank you yeah
thank you very much currently
currently the Atlantic time zone is a
time zone in Eastern Canada Puerto Rico
and the Virgin Islands ends then
obviously going south so um
yeah
yeah it is required that's uh will
require like action from other states
and possibly even the Canadian provinces
and so forth so
all right thank you representative
Schultz
thank you madam chair
um
I am very excited to speak about this
bill as a co-sponsor that is it is a
nonpartisan topic that I care about
deeply and for those of you on the
committee may remember I care about it
so much two years ago that I decided to
to as and I wasn't a co-sponsor that I
signed in to speak after hearing all
your questions and here's why there's a
handful of reasons why first of all
uh the amount of car accidents and work
incidents accidents that happen because
of daylight savings in the time switch
is statistically significant the number
of heart attacks goes up 24 on the
Monday after the time change and there
is even a an increase in the number of
strokes and a temporary increase in the
number of suicides because as sleep
researchers have determined even an hour
change
um in your sleep disturbance
quoting Matthew Walker a sleep
researcher that's how fragile and
susceptible your body is to even just
one hour of lost sleep
and I know this personally because I
actually am someone who is very
sensitive to issues around sleep I have
an autoimmune disorder that one of the
symptoms is an issue with sleep
consistency of sleep is very important
to maintaining my personal health
can you hear me okay
now we can do it sorry I heard an
interruption I apologize
um I'll continue I also
um suffer from seasonal depression and
am very happy to show you my light box
since I'm next to it
um and I know that many people in your
districts if you ask them about this
very much would like to get rid of the
time change issue it is very disruptive
um another issue that I remember being
raised that compelled me to testify last
time and I'm excited to co-sponsor is
because of the confusion that people
assume will happen if this passes and
the group of states a block of States
decide to ditch the time change and I
wanted to reassure you and I think this
is something that representative
Corrigan was trying to point out that I
grew up on the westernmost boundary of
the Eastern Time Zone in Louisville
Kentucky Kentucky and just 45 minutes
south of us was the time change and a
whole section of uh the viewing audience
for the Louisville media Market actually
included this time change so everything
everything on television was announced
uh Eastern and Central Time both times
were listed in everything
um and it really wasn't a big deal maybe
because I was raised with it but many
people live near a time zone change and
quite a few States actually have two
different time zones in their own State
like Kentucky does Tennessee does and
many others and it really is not a big
deal to have a time zone change near you
it is just a matter and fact of a way of
life
uh you just know when you're driving
South towards Fort Knox that the time is
going to change and it is just a matter
of fact of living just like it is when
you know that the time is going to
change here but with none of the uh car
accidents and heart attacks that happen
because of the two times of changes in
um in those issues I also want to point
out that there's a lot of myths around
why we even have daylight savings uh
changes I will send a video out again
that I sent I think two years ago
um that sort of humorously portrays the
myths of why we do it it has only been
about a hundred years that we've been
doing it and it was inspired by a change
that Germany made I think in 1918 but
um really
uh having the two times a year of time
change is very disruptive and most
people hate it and I I think it's only
an excess of questions and an in an
inability to accept change is the only
reason why we haven't ditched it already
when it is so universally despised so I
hope that we will gain non-partisan
bipartisan support however you want to
look at that that and if you are
concerned about this issue I just
encourage you to talk to your
constituents and I especially hope my
fellow Democrats will ask me any
questions and concerns that you may have
I know we've continued to talk about
this bill for the two years since we
last heard it so bring them on
thank you representative Schiltz I would
also like to point out that it's not
just humans that have a problem with
this
um the body clock of my pugs when it's
time to eat you could almost sit your
watch too
many questions for representative
Schultz on her testimony
Representatives
yes thank you
um good morning representative Schultz
good morning representative
I am
listening to your testimony and it seems
that the basic thrust of all of the
problems that you mentioned uh health
issues accidents and so forth are a
result of Changing Times
uh not a specific time in a big Zone
and would that not be true
it is the diff the difficulty comes in
the springing forward and the falling
back two times a year I hope I wasn't
confusing in comparing the two different
there's two sets of concerns that I
remember hearing before so I just want
to make sure I'm clear about them to
live in a specific time zone and have
the spring forward and fall back that
the time changes require creates a
physical difficulty that's one specific
concern and that is what causes the
temporary raise in the number of heart
attacks suicides work accidents and car
accidents the other concern I was maybe
I I hope I was clear is that you know
there were concerns around where the
boundaries of a time zone change might
be and the concerns about New Hampshire
potentially having one on our western
border and the concerns that I was
addressing in that regard was just the
matter of factness it was
to live near a time zone change so
there's significant differences uh and
difficulties raised by experiencing the
time zone you live in changing two times
a year and the desire to ditch that is
huge and living near a time zone
boundary is really not a big deal those
are two very distinct issues so to
switch to what is Atlantic time to then
adopt what we have eight months of the
year with daylight savings so it'd be
adopting what we have during daylight
savings and ditching where we are now to
get rid of that time change two times a
year uh the phys that would be a
physical relief for many people and
um that is the difficulty the difficulty
living near a time zone boundary is no
big deal does that help
I think so
um that was going to lead to a follow-up
question sure
um well I'm is that all right Mr chair
all right with me
good thank you
um and that would be that from what we
have heard uh Vermont is not how shall I
say on board with this program is that
not true
I believe that is how the bill is
written and I and I that the questions
about Vermont is why I felt it important
to explain what it was like growing up
near a Time boundary uh you know a time
zone boundary
um this would move us to the a
westernmost point of the Atlantic time
change and having grown up at the
westernmost point of the
um Eastern Time Zone to Central Time
Zone was really no big deal
the difficulty and the desire to create
this change is in the actual switching
of our existing time from daylight
savings to daylight standard and then
daylight standard to Daylight Savings
um
everyone would just know if this passes
in the other states adopt it and a block
of States then adopt Atlantic time you
would just know Vermont is in Eastern
time and
um there would be signs at the border if
you didn't know but everyone would just
know oh it's actually seven o'clock not
eight o'clock in Vermont and it's no big
deal
follow up
thank you
um okay you just brought up another
issue to my mind you mentioned signs
that you're
uh so there's going to be a cost with
putting up signs that tell people the
time difference is that not true
I believe that would be very minimal the
actual savings you would gain from not
having this big blip and heart attacks
with your health health care costs
Medicare Medicaid costs and the amount
of uh costs that would incur from your
car insurance
uh actually would surely offset that in
a societal sense I can't imagine a few
signs along our border is that expensive
thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative Schultz for taking my
question
uh we hear an increase of heart attacks
and other health issues from changing
time
twice a year
how come we don't hear that same
argument when folks travel from one time
zone to another and back and forth
within a week of each other springing
forward springing back
um
is that being an issue how come we don't
require people uh we don't hear about
the health hazards of changing time
zones when we travel that's an excellent
question I don't know the answer to it
maybe the folks that are
research experts
experts to that question I guess it's
just a comparison of you know not many
of us uh you know when we travel it's
not the same comparison or easy
comparison as it is to an entire state
or town or half of a state changing at
the same time you know we're talking
about a level of consistency and
comparison to the rest of the year on
two Mondays essentially of a year that
an everybody is changing
um but I'll maybe folks that are better
experts at this after me can answer that
question but it's a good question
thank you
representative like us you have a
question uh yes
um there's been discussions of the
alternative Atlantic Standard Time of
going to Daylight Savings Time
permanently but isn't
um those functionally the same as far as
what the time would be and the only
difference is that and perhaps
Atlantic's inner time will be more
straightforward and uh permit daylight
savings time the requirement
actually
that makes sense
I don't know if that was a question but
um is that true it sounds like it's true
you know maybe people don't want to have
their time zone named Atlantic time zone
but I believe that's true maybe the
sponsor the lead sponsor would be better
to answer that question but it is it is
functionally the same as just remaining
in the daylight savings time that we
will be switching to in March
yes
yes representative Pearson points out
that the Red Sox would not be affected
by the schedule change
be right simple way of closing Network
folks yeah all right
we have
time allotted for this for this bill and
three people who need to speak
so
yes thank you
plus two other people that have
volunteered and representative fellows
has a question so I believe that it
would be appropriate to recess this
hearing until 10 o'clock on the 18th
we're not going to finish it anytime
soon
I apologize to the members of the public
who have come to join us but uh
who don't have have the time
okay so we're going to move on to House
Bill we're going to open a public
hearing on House Bill 499 and the chair
is going to
recognize
just speaking on her bill
thank you
house bill for
you please mute yourself
Bill 499 prohibits the state from using
a face recognition
of two parts
first part is a
restriction of
how face recognition technology can be
used in court and this part was
developed by representative birch as a
result of some
difficulties we had with Ace previous
bill on the same topic last session
and it has some very very clear uh
restrictions
there is a later amendment by another
member of the general report who was
also a lawyer who has an amendment that
that restricts face recognition more
broadly
uh I'm happy to support either of them
but I am not a lawyer I am unfamiliar
with court practice and I don't really
have a way to determine the implications
of either of those positions
the part that I concentrated on was part
two which is which prohibits the state
from engaging and face recognition
the
we do currently have a database of Faces
in our driver's license database
and this would prohibit the department
of transportation from using face
recognition on that or allowing it to be
used by anybody
under the process of face recognition
it also bans other other state agencies
to create or maintain a searchable
database the faces
when I researched this over the summer
all of the photo databases were in
Health and Human Services
and they were all
they none of them were searchable by
face recognition you could go into them
by name and say
this person here's a picture of this
person who is an employee of the
department if you want to verify his
presence this is a person this is a
photo of the person of the names you
named who is a licensed plumber and
here's a photo that he can use to verify
this is actually uh
they're all going by name
and find the photo which sometimes you
need to know is who what you can't do is
take a
picture of somebody
and scan that database and say oh this
person who's
whose face came up on a convenience
store robbery photo is actually a plum
named someone such and such so you can
go in with the name and get the photo
that's fine you cannot go in with a
photo of an unidentified person and use
the state's resources to like to obtain
identifying data
that's the part that I that I wrote and
I'm uh at this point none of them are
used that way and I would very much like
to establish the prohibition before
they get into it
and I will answer any questions on part
two and defer part one to the other
to The Experts
um Madam excuse me Mr chair I do have a
question if I may yes representative
Brian
thank you
and thank you representative for taking
my question
um currently now on your cell phone the
technology does exist uh police
departments do use it if I have my cell
phone with me and I went and created a
robbery uh they could track that my
whereabouts via that device also people
do know how I travel with the uh uh with
the transponder that is on my vehicle uh
so how is this face recognition with the
new technologies really different in the
detractability that we're living in in
today's modern world
the main thing is is you your your phone
says the phone is in this location
all right your phone could be stolen and
someone else could use it
and there are no prohibitions in this
bill on any private use of face
recognition or any local uses of face
recognition there is only a restriction
on what the state government does and on
what can be used in court
so if your employer assuming it's not a
government agency say Fidelity wants to
set up face recognition system for
people who are walking into their
offices in Merrimack
that's their business they can do that
thank you
representative crota
[Music]
thank you Mr chair
representative McGuire when we heard
this bill
and it was a year and a half ago
there was
um some kind there were some comments
from the New Hampshire State Police
and
if I remember correctly an amendment was
written to address those concerns
and the components of that Amendment
still in this bill
uh yes they both
both the bill as written and the
amendment to be offered later are
addressed Police use of facial
recognition
um
for all the details
yeah I'll point out that uh Paige page
one looking at the bottom in lines 21
through it appears to be the end do
cover exemptions for law enforcement
um
we have any other questions
it's time for the chair does not see any
other hands raised
on this matter do I have any in the Rope
I do not all right we're going to close
the public here oh standby
um there are other people who have
signed up to speak oh wait oh there we
go okay I did not have hands raised in
the attendees list
and representative Smith
are have both signed up for state and
three other individuals all right
representative church if you can raise
your hand so I can find you in the
attendance list
okay
[Music]
yes
representative Smith
good morning
um my name is Marjorie Smith I represent
Durham and Madbury
um which is uh Stratford eight
District
when this committee last saw this bill
you considered it to be of such
significant importance
that you created a subcommittee that did
an incredible amount of work to address
the concerns that had been raised and to
come up with a bill that you believed
addressed those concerns
Edna passed the bill it went to the
floor the floor passed the bill and sent
it to the Judiciary Committee
at that point at that time I chaired the
Judiciary Committee and I will confess
to you that I consider my most
significant failure as chair of the
Judiciary Committee was to find a way to
have people understand the implications
of facial recognition and the possible
misuse because in the end
the Judiciary Committee voted itl on
this bill
I'm back again because I believe it is
an incredibly important bill and as you
might well be aware since you first
considered this bill we have had
situation after situation where we have
been able to measure both the pluses of
facial recognition and there certainly
are pluses
and the minuses of facial recognition
and there are significant minuses and
because of my commitment to the
importance of personal privacy
and of
um I'm going to use two terms both civil
rights and civil liberties
um I am back today with an amendment
that takes the bill that
um uh chairman Maguire introduced
and attempted to incorporate in it a
recognition of how if used correctly
facial recognition is a plus
but if not used correctly it can create
terrible deleterious
um
repercussions particularly for people of
color and for women
two categories where at least so far the
level of facial recognition technology
has not been able to ensure accurate
um reporting
I have
um given to you Amendment 0247h
it has uh the chairs
uh name on it chair McGuire and my name
on it and what this bill this amendment
tries to do is balance the pluses and
minuses of facial recognition having to
do
exclusively with the powers of the state
and
um
what it does is put in place a very
commonly used and effective tool of a
warrant
to say that in order for the police
to um
use facial recognition
they need award and as you all will know
warrants can be granted very quickly
there's no
um reason to believe that there is has
to be a a significant time delay
and
um
and it makes it possible to
put a belt and suspenders on a system to
make sure that we can get the benefits
of facial recognition but not encourage
the misuse
of a technology that at this point has
not yet reached
um a hundred percent
guarantee of accuracy so
um
I
I think you've read a lot of stories in
the year or more since we last looked at
this bill about how sometimes facial
recognition has been used positively but
also the incredible injustices that have
been caused by the misuse of facial
recognition I believe that this
amendment gets us closer
to where we want to be and understanding
that as the technology improves if it
does improve we can always make future
changes
um thank you for uh permitting me to
give my my testimony
does anybody on the committee have a
question for the representative no I do
representative scitec representative
Smith
um with respect to the uh events at the
national capital recently uh would the
police need a warrant to go after to
start identifying these people if they
thought they were from New Hampshire
well there are two answers to that
question the first
um answer representative scient is what
we see going on today is why I have no
I refuse to use social media what we see
is in each and every case it was the um
perpetrators themselves who took photos
of themselves and broadcasted over all
of the social media
um uh
sites and therefore are completely out
of consideration in this because they
are providing their faces and their oral
testimony that they were there
um in other cases
um and I I believe that it would be
necessary
for the
um the appropriate police agency
to get
um a warrant which again under these
circumstances
um would be issued by any uh
Authority without any delay and it is
the perfect example of the pluses and
the minuses of facial recognition
because it can be used
um well and carefully to the benefit of
the public good but it also could be
misused all that this does is require in
cases where it's appropriate that the
police state
why they want a warrant and
um
for those of us who have
been following at all what has been
going on we know that that warrant would
be forthcoming quickly
representative Smith to chase you just a
little bit on this uh just because they
put their faces on social media does
that mean they're they have been
identified that would still need facial
recognition technology
to your first point
um
yes
that's true but
um for many of them they have in fact
declared
who they are and what they're doing I
also want to say representative scitec
that although I that I am not an
attorney and
um I don't even play one on TV
um uh although I probably could but I
don't like spatial recognition so I
wouldn't want my picture taken
um but I would uh respectfully suggest
that people who are more sophisticated
than I about the use of
um
uh of warrants answer your question uh
because I don't want to mislead someone
I respect so much in the legislature
like Mr representative followed by
representative Allegra representative
kind of following up on uh
representative cytek's question
um I saw in the news last night uh for
the first time they presented some of
the security camera footage from the
capitol itself
uh I don't know if those have been used
uh in an attempt to identify some of
these folks but isn't that wouldn't that
be prohibited from this bill
I can't answer that question
representative
right thank you the federal law
enforcement is exempt from this
yes this bill affects the New Hampshire
government and the New Hampshire court
system anything that happened at the
federal capital in Washington is not
under our control
question of the chair
um in regards to that response
um we understand that some of the people
who did invade the capital were from New
Hampshire so this bill will prevent
um I'm not sure I guess Federal
authorities from using facial
recognition
two no
representative it would prohibit
them from bringing a case against that
person in New Hampshire courts it would
not affect anything they would do in
federal courts which is where I would
suspect they would be bringing such a
case correct I believe that thank you
representative Allegro thank you a
question of Representative Smith
um rightly so I think you're you're you
express concerns about the technical
short comings of uh facial recognition
systems
um
how does allowing for its use
by requiring a warrant
uh let me rephrase that
how does um requiring a warrant to allow
for its use mitigate against the
technical shortcomings
that you're concerned about I I don't
see how it it does
I agree with you I don't think per se
that it does
what this bill attempts to acknowledge
is that facial recognition is here now
it is being used now and it can be used
for good and it can be used for ill and
not wanting to completely deny
the the existence of facial recognition
technology and not wanting to completely
require
um law enforcement officials to be
denied a potential
valuable tool
this is uh a measure along the Continuum
that would require
um law enforcement to
stop and think
and be sure and be on record
as to why they are seeking to use facial
recognition and it is possible in a year
or two or ten
um such a restriction might not be
necessary by then who knows we all might
have these little things embedded in our
foreheads that you know tell everybody
where we are every minute I'm not
counting on that but it's possible as
technology uh
moves along meanwhile we have had too
many instances of where facial
recognition technology was used casually
or without careful forethought and has
definitely
resulted in um in harm
to citizens in our in our country and in
our state
specifically but not exclusively people
of color and women
representative fellows you had your hand
up and you
spoke it away
thank you for a question a question for
either representative Maguire or
um Smith in the version that was passed
last year by this committee it included
a provision that said it was okay for
state police to use this technology if
they were working in cooperation with
federal agents and so that's not in the
new version either the original or the
proposed amendment so is that just
because you think it's not necessary or
is by leaving it out is there does that
change anything
yeah
representative McGuire do you want to
answer that
no I bow to my experts on that part I
did not work did not adopt
the wording of each of that part either
in the original bill or in the amendment
and I I would do the same I would leave
it to
um
the more skilled professionals who will
follow me
thank you that's all
right thank you representative Phyllis
Cher is going to call Mr share
and unmute yourself sir
[Music]
um everybody can hear me now yes we can
uh thank you uh
uh thank you madam chair uh members of
the committee my name is Albert sure
often called Buzz instead of Albert I'm
a professor at UNH School of Law I
um I've been involved in the criminal
justice system for 40 years I've also uh
been very interested in privacy
legislation particularly over the the
last five years I worked very closely
with former representative uh Kirk uh in
the drafting of what is now uh New
Hampshire's unique uh privacy
Constitutional Amendment part one
article 2B so I'm very focused uh
broadly on privacy issues I teach and I
write in that area the opinions I
expressed today are mine only they are
not the opinions of uh the University of
New Hampshire or the UNH School of Law
just to clear up I've filed written
testimony and so I'll try to be as
abbreviated as I can in my presentation
so that I can answer some of the more
technical questions questions that that
I've been hearing
um uh my my I I am noted as opposing HB
499 uh that's how I signed up I oppose
the current version of hb499 and I'll
explain that when I get to that part of
my presentation I am in support of the
amendment that has been filed that is
more simple more clear uh and more to
the point uh in dealing with this that
is the amendment that requires a search
warrant supported by probable cause
issued by an independent endicrow
magistrate so let me give a little
context to all of this I think many of
you are personally at least personally
perhaps professionally familiar with the
context you know in the in the 20th
century uh we really thought about
constitutional privacy in terms of the
Fourth Amendment uh in terms of searches
and seizures and the Fourth Amendment
reads like uh
text some version of physical privacy
your body your house your property your
luggage that's that's the feel and the
language of the foursome Fourth
Amendment uh and that worked fine in the
20th century when we got to the 21st
century more and more we started dealing
with technology that was all about
intangible information what's inside
your cell phone the uh the pictures you
can derive from uh official recognition
technology uh they're basically uh fancy
information uh for you know
surreptitious DNA harvesting where the
people the police follow somebody around
and without a warrant sees a cigarette
belt they cast aside and mine it for as
much genetic information as they can get
what's an issue there is information
rather than the physical item and it
turns out uh the fourth amendment has
been in the 21st century kind of clunky
uh in dealing with that uh trying to
recognize well when you go into
somebody's you know cells that they have
abandoned does that count as a search
you know is that covered by the Fourth
Amendment or when you uh attach a GPS to
the uh bottom of somebody's truck you
don't enter the truck you just attach a
GPS to the bottom of the truck the
police uh do that and then follow it
around for 10 days is the information
they gathered uh acquired from a search
uh that uh protected by the Fourth
Amendment or not so we've run into these
kind of problems when we're talking
about information privacy the fourth
amendment has been kind of clunky in
figuring out whether whether the police
need a warrant whether they don't need a
warrant so uh and facial recognition
technology is a part of that it gathers
as I described the kind of information
uh and you know it gathers information
from somebody in public
you know and part of what the discussion
has been uh in court cases and among
privacy uh Scholars and others uh an
activists has been do you completely
Abandon All privacy uh of any sort when
you go into public
you know Can the police mine your uh the
saliva and the cells on your on your
cigarette butt that you cast aside uh
for all sorts of whatever genetic
information they want without having to
get a warrant to do that you know can
they follow you you know secretly put a
GPS on the bottom of your car and follow
you around for as long as they want
without ever having to get a warrant and
use that information for whatever
purpose they want and uh that you know
and those are all you know privacy in
public questions official recognition
technology is another privacy and public
uh problem
um it's it's it's I'll
now let me um
let me talk briefly about the
reliability issue although I agree with
uh representative Smith that uh this
bill is not a perfect bill I was in in
strong support of the original Bill last
succession that passed this committee uh
uh with a solid majority
um that that that put greater breaks on
uh official recognition technology than
the bills we're working with now
um and I appreciate that that's a
compromise uh it's imperfect compromise
but I think it's a it's very important
to move forward in this way uh with the
uh with um uh with the amendment to HB
499 as it's now written uh my my tech my
written testimony talks in more depth
about the reliability issues so I won't
go into that anymore
um
I I'm in strong opposition to HB 499 as
it's currently written because it is a
pro uh facial recognition bill it allows
the police to do whatever facial
recognition use facial recognition
technology however they want to surveil
someone for 72 hours they don't need a
warrant they don't need to tell anybody
uh they don't need to get approval of
any sort for 72 hours under the uh the
current HB 499 they can do whatever they
want only after 72 hours do they start
to have some some requirements uh to get
a court order but the requirements that
they're that are imposed on them are
completely vague and uh troubling
actually number one it requires a a
police officer law enforcement to get a
court order
it doesn't say that a court order is a
warrant it doesn't say that to get a
court order you need probable cause
it doesn't say what uh what standards
the judge should use in terms of what
are the criteria if you don't need
probable cause what are the criteria to
get a court order it's completely vague
it
apparently studiously avoids saying they
got to get a search warrant
um
um so uh and then further it creates an
exception to that practice as vague as
it is uh it says but a police officer if
he has or she has exigent circumstances
can can go ahead and uh
engage in uh facial recognition
surveillance uh as long as they have
reasonable grounds to believe they could
get a court order remember this is a
court order that doesn't require
probable cause now exigent circumstances
is a term of Art in the legal World
particularly in the criminal justice
system there is a well-known exception
to the warrant requirement that allows
in exigent circumstances where there's
no time to get a warrant and there's
serious risks involved and
officer has probable cause it allows the
officer to act without getting a warrant
the exigent circumstances exception in
HB 499 doesn't require probable cause it
dispenses with the critical requirement
for use of the exigent circumstances
exception under the Fourth Amendment uh
the U.S Constitution and part 1 Article
19 of the New Hampshire Constitution so
uh there are other problems I've talked
about in my uh written testimony what I
think I think HB 499 has currently
written uh is really in uh intended or
otherwise it creates the illusion of
imposing any kind of regulation of any
substance on facial recognition
in surveillance and technology and so I
strongly oppose it that said the
amendment uh that uh offered by uh
representative Smith and and and and and
chair McGuire
um is uh I think is a as a strong effort
to start to regulate uh uh facial
recognition technology it's simple it's
clear it's uh it's to the point uh it
requires that the police get a search
warrant supported by probable cause
issued by a neutral and independent
magistrate as representative Smith said
it uh you can get warrants very quickly
in these days of high technology
um number one uh number two just to use
as an example uh uh uh one of the
members of the committee referred to uh
the capital circumstance
um I think representative Smith was
right in that when people you know put
their uh their uh uh pictures of
themselves on social media websites or
or have them on their cell phone and
offer them up to friends uh you know you
don't need a warrant because they've
already identified themselves as in the
picture to the extent there are other
people in the picture committing
offenses in the picture that are
unidentifiable all the police would need
to do all the D.C police would need to
do or the FBI would need to do was get a
warrant and say I want to use facial
recognition technology to uh to identify
these people and I mean I have probable
cause to believe they're committing a
crime because they're doing it in front
of my very eyes in the in the video uh
clip that I have in front of me so
please give me a search warrant every
judge that I've ever been in front of
will give you a search warrant in that
circumstance so it wouldn't get in the
way at all of the investigation of the
uh uh the so-called Insurrection uh
involving the capital because a crime
and very often with facial recognition
technology used well you have a picture
of somebody committing a crime so all
you need to put in the warrant is the
person in this picture is committing or
has committed a crime a probable cause
to believe that because it's right there
in the picture please give me a warrant
so I can use facial recognition
technology to identify them very simple
process and very easy to get in those
circumstances
um uh to respond uh to uh What uh the
question representative fellows asked
um
this wouldn't get in the way of the New
Hampshire police cooperating with
federal agents and and working in New
Hampshire all it would require is if
they have uh surveillance video of
somebody involved in criminal activity
or they have probable cause to believe
the person in the picture is involved in
criminal activity they'll be able to get
a warrant
um in New Hampshire courts
uh so uh the beauty of uh the amendment
offered by representative Smith and uh
and representative McGuire is it's
simple it's clear it uses a mechanism
that the police are completely familiar
with police in New Hampshire get
warrants very quickly on a daily basis
uh even on a nightly basis
um waking judges up to get warrants so
um I am
um
uh I am uh I'm very much in support of
the uh the amendment proposed to HB 499
and I am very much
opposed to uh the original
um uh HB 499 and I asked the committee
to vote ought to pass on the amendment
to hv499 and more than willing to answer
any questions I have representative
Schmidt has a question for you
foreign
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Professor for your uh very lucid
testimony uh and very cogent testimony I
have two questions one of them is a
slight technicality and the other one is
uh more profound I think so question
number one
um
you
earlier testimony was stated that the uh
the bill only references the state but
as I read lines 18 and 19 of the bill
um the that's 18 and 19 on page one uh
the um the state is defined as not only
what we would consider consider to be
the state that is State of New Hampshire
but also its subdivisions namely you
know city of Dover the police department
of Durham you name it is that am I
reading it correctly correct
thank you so the second question is more
profound and one of the concerns that I
have had and I had when I was the uh the
chairman of the subcommittee that worked
on the previous bill
um was that uh if this if this uh if the
statute were permitted uh permitted the
use of safe recognition technology that
it would be probably irresistible for
towns uh to put up cameras
um on the you know in the public way and
photograph people going about their
business engage in no crimes whatsoever
but creating an enormous data that Trove
that could be mined by facial
recognition technology to identify
everybody that was in those pictures is
that would would that be correct in in
your view uh no yes and no actually or
no and yes would be the best way to put
it uh this bill does not directly
prohibit towns and municipalities from
putting up cameras and recording
everybody going about their daily
business and putting it in a huge uh
storage database although uh what would
limit the towns practically speaking is
the amount of money it would cost to
store all that data but all those videos
but putting that issue aside what this
bill says is uh uh effectively to your
question you can you can collect all
that video you want but a 365 days a
year 24 hours a day of people moving
about downtown Dover right you can
collect all of that put aside the cost
of the storage issue but if you want to
go in there and find out who somebody is
you need a search warrant supported by
probable cause issued by neutral
independent magistrate you before you
can use facial recognition technology to
go in there and identify someone you
need to establish that you have reason
to believe you have probable cause to
believe that a crime has been committed
and by identifying that person uh in the
video that you're you're showing the
judge you would be able you would gain
evidence uh for investigating this crime
solving this crime so in theory you
could create that video database but you
can't access it just randomly and say
hey I want to find out who that person
is you you need to you need to get the
warrant to access it
follow up Mr chair
follow up Mr chair Mr Schmidt follow-up
thank you very much Mr chairman so the
the scenario that we've just been
discussing Professor
um is is it the case that
that that the um that the the ease of
obtaining a warrant would be trumped by
the the fact that this tremendous
database that the that the the town of
Dover hypothetically could have created
uh by putting up a camera that the
um that the the
State
entity in this case the police
department of Dover or the Dover
detectives uh the Dover courts could not
authorize the uh the the town to begin
to search that Trove
um in order to see whether uh an
individual that they're interested in
were visible there uh could not get that
warrant uh because they couldn't they
couldn't demonstrate uh
you know and initially that the person
uh that the person was there and
therefore they couldn't even begin to
investigate using frd correct they
couldn't they would have to have
probable cause to believe that looking
for the presence of that person in the
massive theoretical massive database uh
would lead to probable cause to believe
that a crime has been or was being
committed and that by finding this
person in that database uh they would
gain evidence uh uh in the investigation
of that crime so it would be you know
just the police scanning through this
database to see what uh Peter Schmidt
was doing uh the last week and just as a
matter of you know we don't trust
Schmidt and we want to kind of figure
out what he's been doing they can't do
that
they would need probable cause to
believe that Schmidt had committed a
crime
um and that using identifying Schmidt in
those in those uh video uh those the
surveillance videos would lead to
evidence of a crime so while if once you
have the probable cause
it's easy to get the warrant it's not
easy to get the probable cause it this
bill prohibits by requiring there be the
threshold of probable cause to be met
this prohibits just the random scanning
of databases
thank you I think I'm going to continue
the social distance in my house so that
my face will not be out on the street
there thank you very much for your
testimony you're welcome thank you
representative Schmidt and thank you Mr
Professor share is there any well we've
run into a time constraint we are now at
11 30. we will recess this hearing to 11
A.M on the 18th of February I'm going to
close a public hearing on 499 in my
apologies to the remaining three
folks that wish to speak
I will also be turning the chair back
over to chair Maguire I have a question
of the chair
yes
thank you I had just raised my hand
uh for a question of Mr share will he be
attending that recessed hearing
I may ask my question then would you
rather have the question now or we can
reopen the hearing for one question I'm
willing to answer the question now but I
also will be at the the February 18th
hearing
okay I believe it's just a brief
question Madam chair the hearing on
House Bill 499 representative schuett
your question
uh Mr chair would this have any effect
on the bodies that policers are
beginning
where now
well interestingly if you read my uh
written testimony
um uh uh there's the the one of them the
one of the the biggest provider of body
cams uh uh in the United States to
police departments has made consulted
with its uh expert ethics board an
independent entity and that expert axon
Corporation is the name of Corporation
and their expert panel of scientists and
uh ethics experts has said don't use
this right now
it's not reliable uh and I I go into
more detail in that in uh my written
testimony so uh that's where things are
now as to body camps
all right thank you very much uh for
taking my question and thank you madam
chair for allowing me to ask
thank you representative thank you
Professor share I do hope you will be
able to rejoin us next week uh I will do
so thank you
okay reclosing the hearing on House Bill
499 which is recessed until 11 o'clock
on the 18th next Thursday opening the
hearing on House Bill 544 relative the
propagation of divisive Concepts and I
call Representative
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is Keith Ammon
I represent Hillsboro District 40 which
is the towns of New Boston
Mount Vernon Milford and Hollis
I'm introducing House Bill 544
and I'm doing so recognizing that the
topics the bill covers are controversial
the origins of this bill uh
came from the idea for the bill came
from
a professor
at one of our state universities
who wishes to remain anonymous
due to fear of backlash
so I will I will be I will not be
divulging who that person is
and the idea for this bill uh
is to set policy
guidelines
for
State institutions
and which is why House Bill 544
amends section 10 of the rsas which
cover
State institutions also why
the bill is before this committee
the bill does not do the following
things
it does not apply to private
institutions
with the caveat unless they choose to
contract with the state Institution
it does not ban diversity and inclusion
training
it does not limit academic discussion
and it does not limit free speech
and I I will uh
be happy to address any of those
you can see uh
by reading the bill that those things
are true
so I I understand that the committee has
probably read the bill in advance
but for the record I'd like to read at
least some of the sections
in the bill so that it is on the record
because I think there are
some misconceptions about this bill
floating around
um
this bill addresses something called
critical race Theory
and it is an ideology that is uh
espoused by some people
and the root of the ideology is that the
United States is fundamentally racist
and founded in racism
and that people are born
uh inherently oppressors
and that others are born to be
inherently oppressed so
I'm going to turn your attention to
uh 10 C colon one
Roman numeral two that's the divisive
concept lists
and I'm just going to read through some
of these I'll do it as uh
in a reasonable pace so it doesn't take
too much time
divisive Concepts means that one race or
sex is inherently Superior to another
race or six
the state of New Hampshire or the United
States is fundamentally racist or sexist
an individual by virtue of his or her
race or sex is inherently racist sexist
or oppressive whether consciously or
unconsciously
an individual should be discriminated
against
or receive adverse treatment solely or
partly because of his or her racer sex
members of One race or sex cannot and
should not attempt to treat others
without respect to race or sex
an individual's moral character is
necessarily determined by his or horror
race or sex
an individual by virtue of his or her
racer sex Bears responsibility for
actions committed in the past by other
members of the same racer sex
meritocracy or traits such as hard work
as a hard work ethic are racist or
sexist and were created by a particular
race to oppress another race
and then finally the term divisive
Concepts includes any other form of race
or sex stereotyping or any other form of
race or sex scapegoating and those terms
are defined uh also in that section
so those are the I those are the ideas
um
that are termed divisive in The Spill
because they don't unify our country or
Society they break us up into different
camps we know that
in the American tradition we're all
equal
regardless of racer sex
and uh though the United States was not
perfect in the beginning
the country has advanced to where we're
able to talk about
uh
a better more unity and more equality
but these ideas are Akin you've probably
heard the term snake oil salesman
so there's a new industry that's popped
up that is not regulated very well
and I'm not asking for it to be
regulated but it's a diversity training
or inclusion training
and
there there's an aspect of that industry
that promotes the ideas listed in the
device of concept list
and it's I would liken it to uh to snake
oil as uh
you know proposing to cure a disease but
in actuality
it's even making it worse
and so as
the legislature
it's our job to set policy
for State institutions
and what uh types of training
are appropriate
in the hierarchy of the state
institutions
so moving on the bill the requirements
for the State of New Hampshire that's
section 10c colon 2.
Roman one requirements
the bill simply bans at the State of New
Hampshire the institutions under that
umbrella shall not teach
instruct or train any employee
contractor or staff member student
or any other individual group to adopt
or believe any of the divisive Concepts
so adopt or believe
would be a form of advocacy
thank you
and then no employee contract or staff
member student of the State of New
Hampshire shall face any penalty
or discrimination on account of his or
her refusal
to support believe endorse Embrace
confess act upon or otherwise ascent
to the divisive Concepts listed
that section B
I think got the attention of
our professor friend
uh
that uh there is penalty and
discrimination happening
and then this next section talks about
requirements for contractors so
if your tax dollars went to pay for a
contractor
uh the one of the strings attached would
be that they uh just would choose not to
promote these traits within their
organization
and then it talks about labor unions
that it talks about on the next page C
what if a contractor is not compliant
the bill generally leaves the discretion
up to the Department of administrative
services to decide how
and what um
enforcement actions would be attached to
this bill including with contractors and
subcontractors
so Roman numeral three the department of
administrative Services uh is directed
to investigate complaints
uh received so that's where the
enforcement would come in and decide if
appropriate enforcement and provide a
remedial relief as appropriate
section four is is uh
a critical piece of the bill
it directs the heads of state agencies
to review
Grant programs
and identify programs for which the
agency May
as a requirement of the agency
have the recipient certify that they
are not willing to promote these
divisive Concepts
and then it talks about requirements for
agencies
and I'm going to read this line because
it's very critical it says the fair and
equal treatments
of individuals is an inviable principle
that must be maintained in the state
workplace agencies should continue all
training that will Foster a workplace
that is respectful of all employees
and then it directs the head of each
agency to develop a policy to that
effect
and
it talks about the definition of
training
and then uh number two there it says
agency diversity inclusion efforts shall
first and foremost encourage agency
employees not to judge each other
by their Color Race ethnicity sex or any
other characteristic protected by
federal or state law
and that the commissioner of
the department of administrative
Services shall develop regulations for
the enforcement of the provisions of
this statute
so I I won't I won't belabor the rest of
the points here
but I do want to turn your attention to
the general Provisions section
it says nothing in this chapter shall
prevent agencies or contractors
from promoting racial cultural or ethnic
diversity or inclusiveness
provided such efforts are consistent
with the requirements of this chapter
Roman 2 says nothing in this chapter
shall be construed to prohibit
discussing as part of a larger course of
academic instruction the divisive
Concepts listed
but they'd have to be done so in an
objective manner without endorsement
again that's
the endorsement part is trying to
convince other people to believe
in the divisive Concepts using your
position of authority
and uh
I would ask that any opponents of this
bill
you would ask them which of the divisive
Concepts they support
I think that would be a key question
and this bill is really a bill about uh
about Unity that we're all equal
and with that I'll take any questions
representative Schultz
thank you madam chair I actually have a
couple more than one question Madam
chair depending on his answers if that's
okay
yes okay uh representative Ammon
um do you believe that systemic racism
exists today in America
do I believe that it's systemic does
that mean the system is inherently
racist is that the question does
systemic racism exist can you define
systemic
uh
systemic would be that uh the remnants
of slavery and racist beliefs have been
codified and normalized in existing
systems of government and business and
Society in general
no no it exists nowhere no I'm saying
it's not systemic it does exist there
are vestiges of it and our country has
done a very good job rooting out those
last messages but do I think that the
structure of our country is racist by
Design no
so do you acknowledge the
institutionalized racism of the
Three-Fifths Compromise of the
Constitutional Convention of the United
States
itself
could you familiarize me with that is
that the two-thirds compromise yes it is
that has been uh rectified since
and it slavery is one of the original
sins of our country
but the design of the country the Divine
Design of the institutions of the
country
have allowed our country to evolve
into and and to rectify those sins of
the past so it's that proves that it's
not uh
by Design
I think it proves the opposite of your
point
interesting I have so many more
questions but I know there are other
people that want to ask questions I just
uh there's just one comes to mind as
well because your bill also addresses
sexuality
um IT addresses sex so that would be a
biological definition
biological and gender
it does not address gender
so that's interesting is there specific
um
sexual uh biological sex then that you
are concerned about here does that mean
intersex or people born with different
chromosomal differences that are not
binary that are that kind of biology it
doesn't address any of that addresses
whether you're male or female and that
would be your biological sex
okay one more even though I probably
could ask a hundred more
um
uh so it uh doesn't bother you that uh
researchers have shown that modern day
Society in America has inherent
bias against people for a number of
reasons including race and biological
sex
yes and that's why this bill uh
eliminates that or attempts to eliminate
that and put the discussion on a Level
Playing Field that people shouldn't be
biased against because of their racer
sex those that that that idea is
antithetical to America
I have so many more questions but I
don't want to monopolize thank you
representative Schultz I think
representative Judy you have a question
you'll have to unmute yourself okay yes
thank you I'm sorry about that Madam
chair uh so I'm going to ask you a sweet
question are you are racist
I'm sorry if you are a racist person
I'm really sorry I don't understand
religious person
no no this this is
am I a racist person yes
I don't believe so and I'll tell you a
little reason why I don't believe that
um
I was raised in a faith uh it's called
the Jehovah's Witness faith
and it's probably the most integrated uh
congregation
and it's an international congregation
so
uh when I was growing up
uh
we regularly had
fellowship with people of all Races
and so that's my experience that's the
way it should be
and promoting divisions is toxic to that
and so that's my position
follow up
uh I received so many emails
by my constituents in New Hampshire
around New Hampshire
and they asked me
firmly
to be against
this bill HB
544 okay
because uh
and your question is my question is
why that person stayed behind the scene
why the person you mean the professor
professor yes yes
uh she or he is worried about
retribution and losing their job for
advocating this
uh in their in their personal life and
I'll read you
a piece of any of an email that I
received
and this person made emphasis uh I am
required to inform you that I am a
professor
at XYZ
New Hampshire Public University
and and I'm I'm redacting that
but I'm writing to you as a private
citizen on behalf and not on behalf of
XYZ private university
and the reason that they don't want to
be known is because they're worried
about losing their job
and that academic
Freedom really doesn't exist or losing
it
uh in in at least the public university
system
follow up my name's yeah
Madam chair
follow up please
you've you've been muted representative
Judy please unmute yourself
right now I'm okay right now
okay so that means uh he or she
he knows
what he's wearing here it's one
uh representative Judy you can't assume
they're motives
um
everyone who are listening to me
I am really offended
by HB 544
enough is enough
we live
in the Earth
like an egg
I don't think
breaking the eggs
will be good for anyways
or any man or any human
may I ask a question
we don't I'm not going to answer any
question because I am really offended uh
as a black person what what are you
offended by what aspects are you
offended by also I am proud of myself to
come from Haiti to become here in United
States without speaking English
you welcome me so thank you sir
thank you
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for uh taking my question
uh I am kind of concerned uh with my
background and I'm uh
and let me preface by saying uh most of
the Union contracts that are established
uh one of the first articles uh or the
second article within the agreement or
at some point it does say it will buy by
the laws the U.S constitutions and by
the laws of that particular state
taking that into account looking at what
you are submitting here from line on
page two line 36 down to line 18 you
have gotten quite
explicit in going into some of the
things with the uh Union uh contracts
most of the unions
believe in uh cohesive bonding of a
Brotherhood or Sisterhood do you feel
that this current bill could jeopardize
that in particular and if I could have
your opinions of that thank you madam
chair
yeah thank you for the question
um I've never been in a union so I can't
speak from experience on that um
the idea is generally that state money
if it went to fund a union that
they would follow these basic guidelines
that uh
uh you shouldn't be discriminated
against based on race or sex
if they're already doing that then maybe
that's not
uh a requirement in the bill the the
I think the fundamental piece in the
bill is State institutions and that the
contractors the unions are kind of a
secondary aspect
and mainly because they
receive funding from State institutions
and they operate at the requests
and direction of State institutions
in in the capacity of performing a
function for the state
does that make sense
it does and if I may follow up Madam
chair briefly
um
you you mentioned that the unions
receive funding and just as a point of
correction in my knowledge that I
believe that there is no funding from
the state of New Hampshire into any of
the unions that have any collective
bargainings in the state they are
independent and they're under the laws
Guided by the state of New Hampshire but
there is no funding mechanism I see
you know I'm I'm open to uh
improving the bill so if that's
something that can be improved by
leaving that out
um you know I would be open to that
thank you and thank you madam chair
there's a lot of other people with
questions I'll yield thank you yes
uh speaking of that it is almost noon we
will complete the questions for
representative Anna and then recess this
hearing until 1 30 on Thursday the 18th
and I apologize to all the people that
came out for it but this bill is much
more complicated than it seemed at the
beginning
representative Schmidt you have a
question
thank you madam chair indeed I do
representative Ammon thank you for being
with us this morning I read your bill
carefully and I see that that it makes a
number of categorical statements
um which I think are unarguable uh that
in the absolute
the uh the statement that no one is
better or worse because of their gender
their race uh their sex and uh their
origin whatever uh but so the the the
categorical statements
so if if the um
if the uh if the bill is passed uh can
it actually contribute to a an
improvement of the situation that we
currently find ourselves in because your
earlier testimony does say
uh that you recognize that there there
is racism sexism ageism and so forth out
there
um that that Society is working on
uh but
do you really feel that that your bill
provides a modality for to for getting
to a better uh situation and a better
process than we are currently engaged in
yeah thank you for the question
um
I think this puts guidelines on uh what
what are the limits especially under
the auspices of the state apparatus
that's really what this is about
what are the limits uh
in
presuming that someone has
uh someone was born
to be an oppressor that's really like
the underlying thing of this
or someone was born to be oppressed
uh because of the racer sex that's the
underlying thing if that's the
assumption that we're going to make as a
society then I think we never get to
Unity
um and so that these this this list
is a set of guidelines on what's
appropriate
in in state institutions for having that
discussion
does that make sense
it does you you realize we're up against
the time deadline here are you wanting
to come back because this is a this is a
colloquy that needs to continue in your
testimony and helping us to understand
your bill and your purpose is important
can you come back when the bill whiz uh
is taken up again I'd be happy to and
and I'm acknowledging that this is a
difficult discussion
uh and I
appreciate the intellect of everyone on
the committee to look at this issue and
decide what policies should be in place
for
you know this the state agencies
especially so thank you
thank you
thank you representative and then are
there other questions for representative
Ammon before we uh we close I don't care
I just wanted to reiterate what Peter
representative Schmidt was saying I
would really appreciate if the sponsors
could join us when we reconvene whatever
day and time that will be because I
think we may have more questions for
them
thank you the
uh and to all the members of the
of the community who are raising their
hands repeatedly I am not going to
invite you to speak because the governor
has scheduled his budgeted address to
start right about now
and we need to take a break this meeting
will be resumed
1 30 p.m on Thursday the 18th I hope all
of you will be able to join us then and
I'm sorry for the delay but
when will the committee resume Madam
chair what's that when will the
committee resume today
I haven't gotten there yet but the next
hearing is
30. excuse me 115.
thank you
hey
and we will
resume at 1 15.
for the next bill and I hope we'll be
able to complete some of the hearings
today thank you
we're in recess
my samples
in my committee
foreign
excuse me everyone in the committee room
I just want you to know that I have
muted the um the sound
uh so I can't hear you if you're if you
respond to me but I just want you to
know it's muted and somebody will need
to unmute when you resume at 115. thanks
a lot we are hearing you Pam if you can
hear me can you send a link to the
governor's budget address
I don't know where it is
okay thank you
foreign
[Music]
can you hear us
I can't hear you
I'm gonna test the Mike's chair is that
coming through
loud and clear
stage
okay I'm going once yeah yes I'm sorry
I'm here I was distracted by uh an echo
in YouTube
uh I did not get the uh testimony page I
have them at home and I'm willing to
fill them out after the fact do you want
me to do that
you did not get the testimony page what
do you mean uh you guys the record of
the hearing uh who is present time open
time closed I can do that at home and
submit it when next time I'm here the
question is whether you want me to do
that
um that's fine you know I think I I
double checking the paperwork that I
brought down I don't think I separated
out quite I think there were four
different documents and I think I only
made three piles out of them
I
I have only uh
the attendance which I'm now out of I
wrote there's a one minute warning
the executive session summary sheet of
uh what was uh the motions
I do not have the eight opens everything
when the
what bill number when this is hearing
open when the hearing close
and the testimony which I I don't fill
in but i s uh email it's that page I
don't have
okay well I'll ask Miriam to print them
out and um you know it's certainly
whatever you you know you can do it at
home obviously clearly but um I'll try
to get copies of the the hearing sheets
is what you're looking for sir you print
it out I'll do it at home if she's I
will wait till my next appearance
okay yes I think that would be fine okay
great that's all okay thanks
all right fabulous the time is now
115. we're going to open the hearing on
House Bill 606 and the chair recognizes
the Bill's Prime sponsor representative
[Music]
good afternoon I'm Carol McGuire
representing Merrimack District 29 which
is the towns of Allenstown episode in
Pittsfield and House Bill 606 exempts
from the current Criminal
status of of Performing cosmetology
harboring or or s
Aesthetics without a license
if if it is not 4K
uh this came out during the early stages
of the shutdown in March and April when
barber shops and beauty salons were
declared to be non-essential
and a lot of us started looking awfully
Shaggy and others uh illegally
went to a friend and got their haircut
and
that generated a fair amount of
ridiculed that they were being criminals
by getting their hair cut by a neighbor
instead of a
licensed professional
and right now our our laws do not make
any exceptions whatsoever on this
criminality it is a crime for a group of
pre-teen girls to get together
it is a crime to cut your baby's
fingernails
and so as long this bill simply says if
you're not getting paid
it's not a crime
it may be ill-advised but
uh that's your choice you the state has
no no
this state would have no interest in
controlling or regulating free free
actions
the last time this came up the board
said oh but we never prosecute somebody
for cutting their husband's hair or
whatever and I
strongly object to that policy because I
think that if it's on the books as a
crime it should be enforced as a crime
I would be
and in many cases I I object to having
laws that are selectively enforced
I would hope you all do too
anyway it's a very simple Bill last
running questions like
I have at the end of its titled the
executive departments
earlier which I thought we'd fix it in
there
so who is that on the screen that has
their hand up under executive
departments
I have my hand up is that you me you're
referring to it's going to be you
representative go for it
thank you so first of all representative
McGuire
is it a crime or a violation
according to the current statute it is a
class A misdemeanor
said technically a crime or a
misdemeanor it is a crime it is not a
felony unless you are a
non-natural person that is a business so
if you set up a
illicit Salon as an LLC or whatever that
would be a felony if you simply
uh
at somebody's hair as an individual
that's a big Class A misdemeanor
follow-up
yeah
thank you so if
your bill were to pass
um
are you concerned about the fact that it
opens the door for
all kinds of serious violations of the
requirement that people performing these
actions these Services uh be trained and
competent
now
a follow-up
okay
so are you aware that the people who are
practitioners under the law legal
practitioners
um see lots of openings for illegal
activity which would be you know the
class A misdemeanors at the very least
understand the cosmetologists
Etc are violently opposed to this
but
I can't see that anyone is going to be
doing very much without remuneration
except for their friends or family
and if you go to any drugstore or
Walmart or wherever and walk through the
beauty products you will see row after
row of hair dyes
permanent styling AIDS Etc not to
mention nail polish which is also
applying nail polish is also a part of
this this chapter
these products are available for the
public
there is no crime just it is not a crime
to sell them or to use them on yourself
but right now it is a crime to use them
on somebody else
okay thank you
representative fellows
thank you um representative McGuire I'm
wondering if you might recall not so
much this past year but before seeing on
TV
um things about
people who donate care to go to making
wigs and that there's a cosmetologist
there who who Styles their hair so it
looks nice after the ponytails cut off
and then another example I can think of
is um it's not uncommon particularly in
schools for the male teachers to grow a
beard and they do it for fundraising for
some kind of Charity and usually
sometimes they cut their own but
sometimes they get a professional shave
so I don't you think that there there
are times when people have an
expectation that they're getting a
professional service from somebody who
knows all the how to
um all the rules related to sanitation
yes and anyone who is setting themselves
up as a barber or a esthetician or
cosmetologist
is required to be licensed
however if you're
if if you're playing with makeup with
your your teenage friends or your cut or
you're cutting your husband's hair
because he can't get to the barber shop
I mean that may be ill-advised I cut my
husband's hair and he's still recovering
but it's not it should not be a crime
well just follow up
so so what I'm saying is that these
um beauticians cosmeticians whatever
their their technical title is that they
are it's not uncommon that they are
cutting the hair of people that they
don't know
and or the or shaving a beard of
somebody that they don't know because
it's in connection with one of these
chair chair running raising money for a
charity
so representative this does not prohibit
a licensed cosmetologist or whatever
from performing these acts for free or
for charity that's up between them and
and their business this is for
for non-professionals to
help their friends and neighbors and
their families I I understand your
intent
but the way it's worded a cause a
cosmetician
who don't
my the thing is that the the expectation
of the people who are getting their hair
cut or getting their beard shaved for a
charity that the person that's doing
that ought to know what they're doing
and their assumption would be that they
that the person does but you're saying
just anybody can come in and do this
representative house representative
point of order we're still ascribing
pensions the people we don't know when
in this case are theoretically in
existence
that they that they expect to get
professional care or something like this
and actually just leave it at that
we cannot ascribe
the intentions to other people
representative fellows I I had a talk
with with my hair cutter and she was
doing a charity event and her license
was prominently mentioned in the
advertisement even though she was doing
it for free
she was only doing things she was
trained and actually licensed to do
and I that is the case in other charity
events
all right follow up again
yep go ahead I
I I'm not sure that
um we can be sure that that's what
happens in all charity events but in
that case if you think that that's an
exception do you want to make would you
consider making an amendment to this
bill that says that okay
about the charity events and displaying
your credentials or do you want to make
it make it a requirement that that the
charity events only use a licensed
cosmetician for this kind of thing
no representative fellows I want to
leave that up to the Charities I think
they can decide on their own who they
want to have doing that the chair
trimming or whatever and they are aware
of the training requirements for for
cosmetologists and Barbers and I'm sure
they can get licensed individuals that's
all I'm going to say about it well thank
you for taking my question
[Music]
thank you actually I have a the chair
will have a question for representative
McGuire
um I went to college at Oklahoma State
University where for some incredibly
amazing reason 90 of the women in
Oklahoma have blonde hair
now you and I and all of us know that
there's no way that that's actually true
so when the
sororities or the or the the dorm units
or whatever when they have events where
the where the the girls or even in the
sense of the guys are dying each other's
hair
is that a crime currently in New
Hampshire
yes
okay
thank you because that that
occursionary particular basis
so thank you for the clarity
representative did you have your hand up
you took it down
yes I did but I put my hand back down I
think
I was thinking to ask has been covered
covered okay great thank you if they're
if their committee has no more questions
for representative McGuire we will move
on to another speaker I will the chair
is going to call Vinnie
I hope I didn't butcher that sir hi okay
how's that you're on or uh chairman
what's your name excellent thank you um
chair and members of the committee my
name is Vinnie biaketti I'm a barber
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
and I'm here to testify an opposition of
hb606
if you want to allow mom and dad to cut
their kids hair or their their uh their
spouse is here or take some box coloring
or do their hair paint their fingernails
I don't have a problem with that as a
trained professional it's the allowing
of unlicensed people to cut hair
individuals hair wax put chemicals on
people's skin and scalp with no
education or training and the safety and
proper use of these services that I have
an issue with just because I watch a
video and practice on my friends doesn't
make me a professional in any of these
three categories and this is not a money
issue this there's plenty of work to go
around but I would caution you that this
is the safety this is for the safety and
sanitation issues and preventing people
from becoming ill or severely injured
and that's our top priority
a licensed Barber cosmetologist or
esthetician let's go through an approved
course or even an apprenticeship and in
our training we provide we learn to
provide these services but we also learn
and are tested on sanitation chemistry
anatomy and physiology as well as issues
with and diseases of the scalp the skin
hair diseases that are primarily
associated with follicles of the hair
uh head lice dermatitis how to properly
mix chemicals so the hair in the head of
the person is not burned or scarred
alopecia folliculitis just to name a few
and we also learned the sanitation
prevent procedures to prevent the spread
of diseases such as HIV hepatitis staph
infections fungal infections bacterial
infections lice tetanus and again just
to name a few
services that we provide are actually
pretty significant
I'm a traveling Barber most of my
clients are in medical facilities
Correctional Facilities or or elderly
and infirmed and are unable to leave
their house this kind of service is
allowed by law
I not only have proper equipment to cut
my my clients hair and shave their faces
and perform the services that I'm
allowed to and was trained for but my
instruments Combs and other equipment
are properly cleaned and sanitized after
every service helping to prevent the
spread of the disease and causing
illicitor injury to clients I've also
done the charity
um circuit two you do need to be
licensed for that and we can get a
permit they don't charge us from from
oplc for that I would suggest that if
this bill be changed to allow the
services to be provided by and two
immediate family members only and I'd
ask that you oppose this bill is written
and voted itl
thank you for your time and attention in
this manner and if I can answer any
questions I would be more than happy to
representative
thank you Mr chair I do have a question
now
um good afternoon Mr biochetti
representative how are you I'm fine
thank you
um you mentioned that you have performed
your services in
excuse me somebody's cutting in here
um
let me continue with my question uh you
mentioned that you've performed your
services in settings such as
jails and
um communal errors I'll put it that way
in doing that have you
uh in the process discovered
um for example head lice or diseases or
something that you were able to treat or
recommend treatment for that have
prevented transmission of those to other
people I have we don't we don't treat
and we don't cut hair if we notice lice
or the or the knits eggs we don't we
don't cut hair after that it's it
stopped
um and then I found it in an inmate in
um in a correctional facility and then
you know discreetly said you know come
on over here and then give them to the
co and
um they took care of it from there but I
have found that
as well as other other
conditions that I've not cut hair
because I don't want to cause any more
problems or issues
for a follow-up Mr chair
thank you
um
if
um if an amateur were doing this are
there some conditions that I'm
understanding your concern is that they
wouldn't recognize these problems or
might continue to go ahead and cut the
hair which would then
date the disease being transmitted oh
absolutely
um I do a lot of I and I do a lot of
Razor work so I shave people
um you know
I'm exposed to to other people's blood
sometimes I don't make that a habit
um but you know you have to know how to
treat that or or how to prevent the
spread of that how to contain or prevent
the contamination and prevent the
cross-contamination also you'll notice
you'll you know if you have uh scalp
conditions or you miss mix chemicals and
put them on the on the body and it burns
the body if you don't do it all the time
or you're not trained to know how to use
it properly you can seriously injure
somebody yes
did I answer your question thank you
yeah thank you very much thank you ma'am
the chair has got a question for you sir
yes sir are you
all right I'm 44 I don't I don't dye my
hair I don't do anything nor do I did my
hair I have I went to high school with a
lovely caledonza sharp and dairy with
that being said the
certainly Rite Aid in places like that
sell
numerous products that are
apparently deemed acceptable for the
general public to use in a safe manner
now certainly you know you follow the
directions and there are there are uh
potential for misuse certainly and there
are warnings as such
but with that being said I you know
you've mentioned the mixing of chemicals
and some of the other things that could
potentially happen is there really a
risk
for
for someone to
assist their spouse or
assist their their neighbor with uh
dying their hair out of it
because they're one in essence
you know from a consumer grade
standpoint
I'm not familiar well familiar with with
coloring um the Box coloring stuff I
know that if you you use it incorrectly
you can cause some problems the other
the other part is the esthetician part
um we've given facials and you have
masks I do a thing called a dermaplane
dermaplane facial which is uh in essence
using a razor on a woman's face and then
applying a um
kind of like a mask on on somebody so
you're applying chemicals on their face
it's very easy to burn skin if it's not
done properly if you don't recognize
that there's an issue coming
um it can it can cause some significant
injury to to people so it's not just
about the Box coloring it's about the
other chemicals that are used as well
you have to be licensed to purchase
those products no no
um
there are there are places like Sally's
or
um
Paul Mitchell that you can you need to
be a licensed
professional to purchase those products
but to go to Walmart or something like
that and sometimes you don't even know
what's in there what's in the boxes or
the or the shampoos or things like that
representative
consent play a role in this at all let
me provide a little context
if
my brother asked me to cut his hair
because he couldn't get an appointment
and uh
he asks me and he's
55 years old
um
just consent play a role in any of this
I know people
that have the hobby of skydiving
which is I think probably a little bit
more dangerous than getting your hair
cut
but that person has consented to jumping
out of an airplane with a piece of
fabric on their back
I don't understand why it should be a
crime
for me to cut my wife's hair
can this consent play a role in this
that's my question is is that for me
representative yeah sure thank you
you know in reality
I've seen professionals who
who don't cut hair very well and I also
have seen unlicensed people cut hair
very well cutting hair is is not that
big a deal it's when you start to apply
chemicals uh and you start to do just
because you give somebody a bad haircut
the joke is that the difference between
a good haircut and a bad haircut is two
weeks
um cutting cutting hair is one thing
when you improperly use equipment and
tools and you start to spread disease
from one person to another
that because that person didn't
recognize or understand
um that there is a there's an issue
that's where it becomes a problem hair
is hair is actually pretty disgusting
and it carries diseases as well
um so
it's not so much the the physical act of
cutting hair as it is the prevention of
passing along diseases and and
conditions infections
follow-up representative under current
law cutting the hair is actually part of
the problem
the simple Act of cutting someone's hair
or no remuneration is currently a crime
and uh so uh please address that and and
the other side of this is again just
consent play a role
my kids got a head full of knits and I'd
take care of it
am I Criminal
if if you sure I mean and knits are one
thing because they I mean they live off
of blood so once that happens it's not
going to be a big deal however if you're
cutting hair for friends
you know consent is one thing if I give
you permission to cut my hair and you
cut part of my ear are you relieved from
any uh any liability for that
So and I've and I've had my ear cut in
in barber school
um so it's not out of the realm of
possibility so if you're cutting my hair
and you cause physical damage to me does
that relieve you of the liability of
that act
uh
I'm asking you does consent to play a
role in this
uh well my neighbor actually cut his
hair or my neighbor's wife or he asked
me to put a Blue Streak in his hair
um
[Music]
for sure should it turn me into a
criminal if I if I meet his request and
I and I don't disagree with that if
you're if you're going to put a Blue
Streak in and I asked you to put a Blue
Streak in my hair that's one thing you
put a Blue Streak in my hair and you
burn my scalp while you're doing it
that's something completely different I
didn't give you permission to hurt me
so I guess that would be the the
argument to the consent
um yeah I mean cons consent is one thing
liability is another
as in anything else
representative O'Brien
thank you and uh thank you sir for
taking my question and I'm not really
trying to be funny here but I could see
it
do you see any religious
ramifications to this such as if uh
somebody belonged to a monk and it was
in that Cloister uh the terminology if I
think if my memory is right is uh a ton
sure of where you get your hair cut and
certain religious sects do that and I've
always assumed do they go to the barber
or does a brother monk provide that
service and if a brother monk does
provide the service by this description
what they
be in any violation of their religious
freedom in doing that
[Music]
the statute and I do appreciate the
comment on uh by a fellow representative
on that thank you
you know I guess technically
um
you know this the statute says that
their person's engaged in the in the
practice of Barbering cosmetology
Aesthetics uh manicuring in a charitable
benevolent institution nursing home
long-term care facility assisted living
facility
um where such practice is carried on
solely for the benefit of the residents
of such Institution
that's how we get away with doing them
in a nursing home a correctional
facility the hospital those kinds of
things
you know when you start to get into
being in a um you know Convent or
Monastery I don't know if that would fit
the
um that definition
so there are exemptions there are
exemptions for
not having a license to cut hair
and representative McGuire was correct I
mean technically you know your your
daughters are having a you know a
sleepover and they're painting each
other's nails and technically that's
illegal is anybody going to do anything
about it no no it's I mean it's common
sense but I've also seen people who are
cutting hair not for renumeration but
they're getting renumeration
because they're not licensed so they're
they're doing the services they're
performing
um you know they're performing services
on people
and again it's not about cutting hair
it's about the transmission and the or
the prevention of the transmission of
diseases and infections that's my
biggest that's my only gripe about this
so Mr vegetti so you're okay I guess in
essence with Selective enforcement
within the statute
well so
if they're if they're going to enforce
it and they enforce it that's one thing
we have like think two inspectors for
the whole state of New Hampshire
I know there are maybe 1500 Barbers and
15 000 cosmetologists and I don't know
how many estheticians
um selective enforcement is one thing
common sense is another
representative schuett do you have a
question
yes I do thank you
um
just thinking back to the comments made
about
boxed dies that one can buy uh in
various stores
um
I have to admit I have used them myself
would you believe Mr mayachetti that
those boxes always have warnings
inherent in them
and always recommend that someone that
use them would do a test on themselves
to be sure that they don't have an
allergy or a problem with the chemicals
and would you believe that most people
probably ignore those warnings I would
believe that yes ma'am
all right thank you Marissa branchetti
for your testimony we're going to the
chair is going to call
Janine Chapel
hi my name is Jean Chappelle
and I am the school owner member of the
New Hampshire Board of barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics
um and we I am representing the board
today not myself personally
um I want to say first that I can answer
several of the questions that were asked
um by the representatives earlier in
this conversation
um I would also like to say that we
strongly oppose
House Bill 606 as written no other
licensed profession has exemptions for
unlicensed workers to perform their
activities legally just because they are
not being paid
licensing protects the public health and
safety in our industry and is not
intended to extend the arm of the law
into someone's home where a private
citizen might unclog their neighbor's
drain or help someone turn a light bulb
or change a fuse or cut their child's
hair there already are in place
statues laws and rules
that allow for
individuals who are licensed to go into
people's homes who are Homebound and
take care of their hair
um
as far as consent I would say that
consent plays a huge role in that
somebody who consensually allows someone
in their home
to practice some form of hygiene on them
is also not likely to call the police on
that person to report them for
performing an unlicensed activity
please
deem this bill in expedient to legislate
as written the Board of barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics opposes bill
606.
thank you
any questions from the committee
seeing that I will then uh
close the hearing on House Bill 606.
the testify
yeah
Thank You by opening the hearing on
House Bill 575 and call Representative
cordelli
in that case representative introduce
the bills
sponsors here
sure
so my name is representative Mark Lago
I'm from Grafton 7th District covering
the town of Camden
and I'm introducing please correct me if
I'm mistake because it's filing for my
bills here
HB 575
correct
which is an act relative to licensure of
applicants for cosmetology Aesthetics
and manicuring
uh if I'm reading correctly the bill
expands the use of apprenticeship
programs in those fields in qualifying
for licensures cosmetologists manicures
or esthetician but for the barbering
cosmetology anesthetics and manager are
there any other students
whether or
not going to take questions
yes and uh
clearly not qualified but still willing
to answer any questions that I made from
the general public work on the committee
seeing that thank you
Mr Chappelle you signed up to speak
would you uh care to speak now
I would thank you representative McGuire
um again I'm Gene Chappelle I am the
school owner member of the cosmetology
Board of New Hampshire and it's
cosmetology barbering and Aesthetics
um as far as House Bill 575 goes in a
shop apprenticeship program it is widely
accepted as in other professions that
the instructor is a current practitioner
who is continuing and working to
maintain their own practice and
profession for their own income
this of course means that the Apprentice
student is the second priority and is
either watching or practicing alone
while they are in a shop apprenticeship
program not getting undivided attention
therefore needing more time to become
proficient also the instructor is
currently not required in the shop to be
a licensed instructor
any licensed cosmetologist Barber or
esthetician can be a an instructor for
an apprentice
that is a dangerous situation for that
Apprentice
we are still not opposed to the
apprenticeship program there is
absolutely room for an apprenticeship
program the other
consideration with the apprenticeship
program is that it is one Apprentice per
practitioner unless you are a barber in
which case you can have two apprentices
so it also actually limits the amount of
apprentices that can be taught
um the instructor is currently not
required in the shop to be a licensed
instructor just a practitioner therefore
they may not have any teaching education
or experience so again it is more
important
um to have more time with that
practitioner in a school setting it is
required that all instructors are
licensed and the primary goal of every
instructor is the education of the
student and that is their first priority
it is their only priority they are not
maintaining a clientele while they are
teaching the students in fact they are
prohibited from doing their own clients
during school hours at the school while
they are teaching so they're providing
undivided attention to the students
which is why the hours are reduced and
The Apprentice hours are increased
when a student is receiving uh
instructed from a licensed instructor
who is not permitted to work on their
own clientele they are getting a
different situation than they would get
in a shop situation where they are very
different and require very very
different time demands
um and speaking for the Board of
Cosmetology barbering and Aesthetics we
oppose House Bill 575 for these reasons
ready
uh I just want to show you something
command so
looking at uh
Bishop I presume you have the bill in
front of you I do
so as I'm reading starting in line 19
that paragraph area where it talks about
have you know completed a course of at
least 600 hours
with the new language basically then say
which shall not exceed 600 hours we have
put that number at exactly 600 hours
because if it cannot be at least if it
cannot be more that that's it that's the
number is is the issue with the 600
hours as a number or is it an issue with
the overall process of having uh
apprenticeship exists
restricted time frame
the problem is that currently
um for the the required hours in a
school for cosmetology is 1500 hours the
requirement for the apprenticeship
program is three thousand hours as it
should be the requirement for Aesthetics
in a school setting is 600 hours and the
requirement for an apprenticeship in a
shop is 1200 hours as it should be
um the the requirement for barbering for
a master Barber is 1500 hours in a
school setting and it is 3 000 hours in
a shop setting as it should be
um what we are opposing is the reduction
of the requirement of hours for in
in-shop apprentices
does that answer your question no so
you're saying that this bill is going to
drop that from 3 000 hours down to 600
hours
no there are there are several
disciplines that are um that are managed
under the Board of barbering cosmetology
and Aesthetics all of these separate
disciplines have separate requirements
of hours in order to complete the
requirements to appeal to test for your
practical exam and your practical and
your written exam for your state license
currently Cosmetology in a school
requires 1500 hours of Education as it
should currently
the in-shop apprenticeship requires
three thousand which it should
all the rest of the disciplines have
separate hours of requirements for
example nail technicians if they're in a
formal School setting need to have 300
hours in a licensed school in order to
appeal to get their state license
through the Practical exam and the
written exam
in a salon setting they need to
Apprentice for 600 hours because they
are not they're not in a formal School
setting
thank you Ms Chappelle that's very clear
are there other questions
seeing none thank you very much
no one else has signed up on House Bill
575. is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
raise your hand if you do know
very good I will close the public
hearing House Bill 575
Adam chair uh if I may I have a question
of the chair
um
looking back at House Bill 173
which according to my notes we exact on
January 27th
motion by representative Roy seconded by
representative goalie and we voted at
octopass for the consent calendar but
I'm still not seeing the status of that
bill showing that a report has been
yes
the committee report was lost in the
email for a while I have finally seen it
and it is working its way through the
system the staff
as a flood right now thank you very much
I was afraid something like that might
have happened
we have three minutes before the next
hearing so everybody stand up and
stretch
Carol can you hear me
yes Peter
uh um
I haven't had any acknowledgment of the
blurb that I sent to you Pam and Miriam
a couple of nights ago on cacr7 did you
receive I received it and passed it on I
just put in the words that you said
insert uh function here otherwise
okay I I just didn't I hadn't had any
feedback I just wanted to make sure that
uh it hadn't gone off into cyberspace
so I encouraged the committee to assume
that they've written a wonderful
wonderful blurb and it has been moved on
and uh
if I if that's not the case believe me
we'll be getting in touch with you
well I I figured that you might well
contact me uh inquiring uh as to the
status of the blurb but again just
because ordinarily I hear something back
I I since we have
figured I'd waste them this way
if I'm working its way through ecosystem
terrific thank you
oh man that's had to answer the covet
screening questions
[Music]
by the way if you answer any of those
shot no no this is for oh okay
there it is
I'm wondering you since since everybody
is walking around and taking a break
um does it seem to the people in the in
the committee room as it does to me that
the sound quality today is not up to
what it has been recently it seems like
there's a kind of the and kind of a
sharp edge to the sound and a lot of
enough background and noise that it's
not great on our end I think it's
dramatically
exactly dramatically better that's the
same to me I don't know
okay
he's fine to me so I don't know Peter
yes sometimes
my phone you might need to move to
another part of your house I found that
to help sometimes or turn off the video
the videos yes
exactly and sometimes I have to turn off
the Wi-Fi access for my zoom and use
actual cell phone bandwidth through my
my cell provider rather than Wi-Fi so it
varies
two o'clock
open the public hearing 444
we all set Madam chair
yes sir please speak okay
um I did submit my written testimony and
as I promised I will not read it
uh but I will go over it
so for the record my name is Gary
Merchant I'm a representative
from Claremont New Hampshire Ward 2. and
I'm here today to introduce house bill
444.
the intent to House Bill 444 is to make
some technical changes to the RSA 318
which governs the pharmacist and
pharmacies
so in sequence the first one I'd like to
talk to the committee about is
compounding for those who've been on
this committee for a few terms
you may go back and
remember that there was some just some
concern about the pharmacy board with
inspecting Physicians offices related to
compounding
the challenge the board faced at that
time and still does is the fact that
compounding
in the law requires the board to comply
with USB standards not to utilize the
standards but the time in which the
board was looking at Physician Offices
the board was not allowed to use the FDA
standard which was drug preparation
which is the final stage of bearing a
drug to a patient through the
manufacturing process
and because of that conflict the board
had no choice but to sort of enforce a
law
that it really didn't believe in but
unfortunately law required it
so what I'm trying to Simply do today
with change in the language is to allow
some flexibility for the board
to use the standards or any other
standards that they feel are applicable
to the world of compounding without
getting into a situation where they
blindly follows national standards that
the board may not
believe is appropriate for the State of
New Hampshire northward citizens
and this is coming from my 10 years on
the board serving the last two years as
the president so that's the first one
with compounding is this simply taking
the word shall and saying they may
utilize the standards
on to the next one is the word of
inspecting of pharmacies I'd like to
leave that one if I may Madam chair
towards the end I think that's the more
challenging one
in regards to the work of labeling the
prescription
the days in which a pharmacist was a
soul person behind the prescription
counter in which they receive the
prescription
fill the prescription wrote the
prescription typed the label and
everything else there was really one
person in the pharmacy doing the work
and that was the pharmacist a comp a lot
of times they may have help from
um at that time support staff they
weren't technicians per se what's
happened over the course of time is that
the restricting filling process has now
been broken into various steps so you
have the intake of the prescription
which is I believe the most critical is
for the pharmacist to review that
prescription and make the determination
whether they should fill it or not
so therefore we created the licensed
technician last time to allow the
technician to do the product
verification to the final stages with
the technical side of building a
prescription
so I think it's more appropriate to
include the initials of the pharmacist
that actually reviewed the prescription
who approved the prescription
than a person who may be on somewhere in
that chain of events to say
that's the person that the patient's
looking for or anyone else and
definitely using the pharmacist in
charge initials doesn't tie it back to
the actual prescription so what I'm
trying to suggest in the bill is to
allow for the board
to require the initials of the
pharmacist who did the review process
if you go back and look at
collaborative practice
the challenge with collaborative
practice
one of the challenges and it became very
evident today with Telehealth
to require a patient to sign an
agreement between a pharmacist and a
provider
means that they have to review the
agreement
understand the agreement
and assigned consent to the agreement we
do not in any other part of medical
community that I know of require a
patient to sign a document like that we
don't ask them to sign and review the
document between a position in the
VA we don't ask them to assign a
referral to go to physical therapy or go
to a lab
so what I'm asking for here is to not
require the patient to sign the
agreement they still have to give their
consent because ultimately if they
decide to go for the referral or not
that's their choice
and then number two the word attending
is problematic because it provides a
level of ambiguity
and what I'm trying to get to there
is that when you talk about attending is
the primary care physician or is it the
doc who's taking care of a particular
disease state today most patients go to
multiple Physicians multiple providers
if you have a cardiologist you have a
rheumatologist you have a orthopedic
surgeon and so forth you may be under
their care but you're not their primary
care so by deleting the word attending
and making it more broad dealing with
the patient's practitioner it allows for
each practitioner the patient sees to
enter into a collaborative agreement
with a pharmacist
so that's the intent between those two
changes one is not to require the
patient to sign the document and to lead
the word attending in order to broaden
the scope to allow patients to see
multiple Physicians to have multiple
agreements with providers
in regards to permits and fees
that's something we talked about last
time when this was before the committee
which I sat on
by the way it's good to see everybody
all again even though it's virtual but
what happens is that we have a situation
now in Pharmacy the roots of Pharmacy
was you had an independent Pharmacy
and it was owned by a pharmacist
and the pharmacist and the owner were
basically wanted the same
those days are gone most pharmacies
today are owned by Corporate America
and the pharmacist is still responsible
and accountable to the Board of Pharmacy
for compliance of all the rules and
regulations
however that person no longer owns the
pharmacy and therefore does not have a
lot of control over the resources to
operate that Pharmacy and to operate it
safely so what I'm advocating for in the
bill and suggesting to this committee is
that we level the playing field and say
both parties have responsibility to the
board both the pharmacists in charge as
well as to the owner the owners
responsible to be sure that the
appropriate resources are provided to
the pharmacist in charge
and the pharmacist in charge is
responsible to use those resources
appropriately so it's a joint
responsibility equally accountable to
both so that's why the change in the
permit fees and the language with the
pharmacist in charge that we actually
have the pharmacist in charge and the
permit holder equally accountable
the last one is the inspections
after we talked about that last year and
again in house bill it was 1655 a 35
the committee agreed that this was
something to talk about for future
legislation
what I am recommending to the
committee
based upon experience on the board
that we still allow the Board of
Pharmacy who has the expertise to write
the rules and regulations on how drugs
are stored how they're handled how
they're disposed of and so forth that's
their expertise
they go into a none Pharmacy provider's
office a dental Veterinary whatever it
may be
the differences here if they find in a
fraction
the board does not act on that
infraction the board then takes the
investigation or the
results of the
inspection sends it over to the
appropriate licensing board they are the
ones responsible if they want to
to
entertain how they want to impose any
discipline onto their licensing the
Board of Pharmacy has no jurisdiction
over that licensee it strictly goes back
to the licensing board for them to
review and then determine what they want
to do with the information all the board
is doing is doing the inspections on
their behalf and then providing the
documentation back to the respective
licensing board for them to look at and
review and act on not the Board of
Pharmacy
so those are the five things I'm
proposing to this committee on house
bill 444
and I'll open it up to questions
do you have a question Madam chair yes I
see representative Schmidt
thank you uh excuse me I don't have my
camera on it right at the moment Gary
but uh I'm looking at the text of the
bill uh look at line four
okay you got it I have it okay do you
see that it doesn't it doesn't seem to
work in English
line three ends with the word specific
then you pick up uh agreement between a
pharmacist and then says and
close parentheses and and
that doesn't work in English
I think representative Smith I would say
I'm going to send you down to OLS to
help them out
well you're the one that needs to have
the language say what you wanted to say
I hear you thank you okay so uh that
that that's just part of it
um
thank you madam chair uh so you
you mentioned the words at some point
I'm not finding it right at the moment
where the word may instead of Michelle
well in the language last year I
proposed to have a May and leave the
inspections if you will going to the
Board of Pharmacy and I'm proposing that
the board still has the authority to go
in which is the shell but if they find
anything with the inspection it goes
over to the respective licensing board
that's the change
I don't know why well I saw it earlier
when I when I read the bill
um but it said shall be subject to you
um and and that shell was struck and was
may be subject to I'm not finding it in
the in the bill text at the moment I am
looking at hb4 444
and somehow I'm not finding it but in
any case uh maybe subject to shall be
subject to seems to me then that there's
no real difference between maybe subject
to and shall be subject to frankly but
um
so think about that I'm not sure that I
want to strike shell
and substitute May for in when in the
phrase shall be subject to or may be
subject to and I want to think about
that further or Bounce It Off Of You
um but then my my second second question
is with regard to uh whether you have
any opposition to your proposed language
from the board or anyone else the the
board of pharmacies in full support of
it
um I did run this by them uh to ensure
that I wasn't running afoul of the
intent of the board or the desire of the
board so the board did vote on this bill
and did approve it
thank you
fellows
thank you madam chair
um representative Merchant I maybe I
heard incorrectly I thought when you
were talking about the labeling that you
said you wanted to have the initials of
the person who checked the prescription
on the label
is that what you said
it wasn't my intent if I said it
um what I was trying to communicate was
that the person who reviews the
prescription when it comes in
it makes the determination to have the
prescription filled
you want their initials on it yes ma'am
yes representative fellows what I I
don't see where it says that can you
point that out
hold on
actually it doesn't you know
so also I can't find that may and shell
thing either
yes for the question about the
prescription label is online
starting on line 13 on page two and it
doesn't require the name or name or
initials of any pharmacist as amended so
represent the merchant if you if that's
what you intend would you uh please
review the language and make sure it
says that I will definitely thank you
for picking that up Fitness uh
representative fellows um I definitely
see that that was left out of the bill
so my apologies to the committee for
leaving it out I will definitely go back
to OLS and get an amendment or I I can't
but the committee I can work with
somebody on the committee if you'd like
I don't know who that would be to on
Amendment or I can make an amendment and
have it sent to somebody on the
committee because it's now the
committee's bill
what thank you representative fellows um
fellows uh you can find the May if it's
there I don't see it either
representative
you have any comment about changing the
attendant physician
to practitioner
the attending physician I'm interpreting
to be the primary care physician is that
correct that's where the ambiguity lies
because the way it's written if you look
at the definitions in RSA 318
it says the one with primary
responsibility for
um the therapy so it's kind of I guess
the actual language for you
representative Brody it does open up a
level of ambiguity and that's been a
concern both by the Board of Pharmacy
and by
um providers and pharmacists trying to
understand who can actually get into an
agreement if you will So to avoid the
ambiguity my recommendation is to strike
the word attending which applies Primary
Care
um versus looking at the person who's
responsible for the disease management
whether it be diabetes and Cardiology
follow-up please
I guess I'm going to be allowed a
follow-up question so
I guess I'm my concern is it where is it
addressed that
subscription prescriptions by a
specialist
are um tied into
the primary cares record for that
patient
so let's say cardiologist recommends a
medication and a primary care physician
recognizes that this might be a problem
for that person based on another
specialist that he's going to or they're
going to how does that work with all
this or is this not or is this not the
place to address that I believe
represent it is not actually the role of
a pharmacist it's accepted the the
pharmacist is trained to look for
interactions
but the ACT
but the actual transfer of information
between Specialists and primary care
physicians is the responsibility of the
doctors
thank you
representative lacas
uh yes thank you
I have a question about the differences
in the standards uh
or things are right and uh in general
tendency that uh
USP standards are too strict not strict
enough for just wrong I was curious
about that maybe an example of one
to help well I think the one is
representative which one Speaking please
Marcus
okay representative
I'll give you an example back to the
compounding issue that we talked about
before where the board
um went in to do inspections and had to
utilize
the USB standards there are times which
we go into a provider's office and many
times the inspector does more education
than inspecting
um so it's one of those things where
we're trying to thread the needle
between
having regulations on how we store
things and be consistent about that
throughout the state
and then to inspect against those
standards but when you find
in a fraction or find something that
doesn't meet the standards The Falls
below the standard that that is then
report to licensing board an example
could be
um this is back to the federal
government if you have controlled drugs
every two years you're supposed to do an
inventory on May 1st was we changed now
to do it once a year but the federal
government requires that each
practitioner
do account
so in that case when we go into the
provider's office and try to help them
we find out that the inventory has not
been done according to federal law
what we did in the past was the board
would issue a fine
what this bill does is say okay when the
board finds that
that line is not levied by the board
that information goes back to the Board
of Medicine the board of dentistry
whatever it may be and for them to make
the determination if there should be a
fine for that infraction
representative O'Brien
thank you Bob
Madam chair I'd like to thank uh first
representative fellows I did have that
same question with the labeling but uh
thank you representative for taking my
question on
um lines four and five on page one uh
you seem to have struck out the patient
a patient's authorized representative
uh does that include somebody that has a
medical proxy like in the case of an
elderly patient or somebody that is uh
mentally a physically incapacitated uh
that person who has that proxy cannot uh
you know interject on the patient's
behalf
thank you for the question
representative Ryan uh no it's actually
the other way instead of requiring
either the patient or the patient's
authorized caregiver to sign the form
which is difficult with Telehealth they
can give their verbal consent
and not have to think you've been a
written consent
okay
are there other questions for
representative Merchant
representative Pearson
thank you madam chair and uh it's I know
you necessarily see me but it is good to
see you uh my old friend
uh I have a question in reference to you
said when you were talking about
National standards
and using a state standard
maybe I'm a little confused I thought
you said that there was there would be
circumstances where the National
Standard would not be followed
but the state standard would
did I hear you right or am I confused
um
obviously I didn't say it
clearly so thank you representative
Pearson it's good to see you as well
um although I good to hear you I guess I
can't see you
um in saying that what I'm trying to do
with the change is to allow the Board of
Pharmacy the some flexibility where they
can use the federal standards
when it makes sense and it doesn't have
a conflict with State Standards
um to allow the board to set State
Standards based upon Federal standards
but not require them to follow them
blindly the issue that we ran into was
that the FDA standard which is also a
federal standard the board could not
utilize in the word the definition of
compounding because it's not part of the
USB standard so we had two federal
agencies with different standards that
conflicted with each other
and it created a problem for the board
because the board was bound to follow
the USP standards for the law and could
not entertain the FDA Federal standards
that would also have eliminated a
problem
thank you
so the the state
okay my experience as you as you know
another world we'll see in the fire code
where we don't necessarily we have state
adopted National statements and there
was no over why National statement so
it so just keep that in mind as this is
my frame of reference so here the state
standard that you're talking about has
to be an equivalency or greater than the
National Standard it cannot be less
or reduced from what what a National
Standard is Right today that's correct
however when we impose
on a board or anyone else in our state a
National Standard the state has no
control over or any influence over
then we don't have any flexibility
within the state
to make a determination that that
particular standard doesn't fit the
needs of our citizens here in New
Hampshire
[Music]
and you're aware that it's a glowing
example the state of New Hampshire
adopts a fire code to which we carve out
certain things that the state of New
Hampshire deems potentially problematic
for whatever reason
why would the pharmacy board not operate
in a similar manner where you would
adopt say the USP standards
with the exception of X Y and Z to fit
what's going on in New Hampshire
thank you for that question
representative Pearson
I think we start carving we could carve
things out of the USB standards
um so we can say these are exceptions
that the board doesn't have to follow or
has to take and determine whether they
should apply or not I mean that's
another approach to it
um what I'm suggesting is that instead
of trying to get into a list of all the
things that the board thinks is
problematic I would suggest that we say
the board can adopt the standards based
upon the needs of the board and what the
citizens of the state need the challenge
we have here is that at the federal
level for instance we had two standards
and they were in conflict with each
other
so if we have
an state agency only following one
standard it doesn't have the option to
look at the other agency at the federal
level
and look at their standards because
they're not allowed to
do I understand you correctly to say
that
the where oh where does the state adopt
the USP
who doesn't
if you look into the compounding
and you look onto the bill on line 23
all compounding should be done in
compliance with
USB standards
okay so did the Florida pharmacy at some
point actually adopt the USP yes they
did and that's what caused the heartburn
Madam chair because when we looked at
the compounding being done in Physicians
offices and things that we're doing with
Remicade specifically
the way they were compounding it and so
do today
violates USB standards but not FDA
standards
lovely
absolutely lovely so what I'm suggesting
to the committee is to allow the board
some flexibility that when there are
conflicts at the federal level and
conflict within standards is that the
board has some flexibility about which
way to go with the standards not getting
in the same situation we had last time
I think this needs more work but not
necessarily in the context of this bill
but this that sounds like a invitation
to disaster
that we multiple Federal standards that
apply that don't necessarily agree with
each other
I'm sure that's kind of the the intent
of the bill to try to get some
flexibility to it and avoid things we've
had done or the bridges we've crossed in
the past that cause some heartburn
hey I I can see that you're dealing with
one specific issue but
the USP is a fairly substantial code and
I and I would imagine there are other
cases where it conflicts with other
other
I don't care yes there are other areas
but you're right it's not a time for
the committee to address it in this bill
representative
um Merchant did we not address this
compounding issue last year
I mean I I seem to remember a bill about
compounding in the pharmaceutical board
I thought we we had already and the USP
in the conflict I thought we'd already
fix that representative that bill was
retained and therefore couldn't uh it
was held for interim study because of
issues not necessarily this one
okay follow-up then is this do these did
this does this bill run tandem to the
other one is it is it in conflict or is
it a advanced version of the other one
yes Advanced version
okay thank you all right representative
Schmidt you have another question I do
Madam chair thank you
uh so I see that there is a uh
submission by uh Dr Conway I believe is
he listed to speak to us
uh yes people speak to us but he can't
today he has a conflict
uh he did I hear you say he's not going
to speak because he has a conflict he
has an emergency he was signed up to
speak but he will not be able to okay
thank you that's I want to make sure I
understood you correctly uh so as you
may know representative Merchant uh Dr
Conway has uh sliled uh a uh thing with
the committee in in opposition uh to uh
some aspects anyway of your bill are you
familiar with his uh with his letter
yes I am I think the intent of what he's
asking for is for the Board of Pharmacy
to not have any authority to go into a
provider's office to do inspections
um I do have a concern about that
because
the reason why we started doing
inspections in the first place many
years ago was because the boards of
Pharmacy nursing
dental and so forth came to the Board of
Pharmacy asking for us to do inspections
through an mou so that's kind of the
root of all of this is that the
respective boards recognized that
Pharmacy had the expertise
had the inspectors and asked the Board
of Pharmacy to do the inspections on
their behalf it then evolved into no
longer having an mou for many different
reasons a lot of dealing with
funding mechanisms and that's what got
us here today
so you know you are you are aware that
there you recall of course and know
you're aware of it you recall that there
was a big flap when uh Pharmacy Board
inspectors went into doctors offices and
I think kind of like shut them some of
them were shut shut down pursuant to the
inspectors uh you know reaction to
things they found uh there was a major
flap between you guys in the in the docs
about that uh is this
a continuation of that it's trying to
resolve that issue
so that instead of the Board of Pharmacy
having jurisdiction over their providers
when they find it in a fraction
what they're doing is taking the
documentation and turning it over to
respective licensing board for them to
act on
Madam chair are we going to see see
somebody hear somebody from the medical
side uh in in doctor's place I'm call
queued up and ready to speak as soon as
you stop asking questions
wow thank you shut me up okay
possible
yes
I'd like to call Nancy Wilson please
uh you should just unmute yourself Ms
Wilson
Ms Wilson
she just showed up on our um deck can
you hear me now yes there you are thank
you for just
uh let me uh show you who I am good
thank you madam chair and members of the
House executive departments and
administration committee
my name is Nancy Wilson and I am
speaking for the New Hampshire nurse
practitioners Association of which I am
a member
the New Hampshire nurse practitioner
Association is the professional
association in the state dedicated to
serving as the voice for nurse
practitioners
we wish to register our opposition
to hb44 as introduced
the bill appears to be a rewrite of
sections of 2020s hb1536
which your committee considered and sent
to interim study on a 19-0 vote
less than a year ago
the committee report to the house
said that multiple professions had come
out in opposition to hb1536
and that interim study was needed quote
to clarify definitions and resolve some
of the inter-professional disputes
unquote
but work on
hb1536 was curtailed by the pandemic
and to our knowledge
those outstanding questions have not
been answered or resolved
our association opposed the 2020 bill
the primary issues we identified for
nurse practitioners
were the definition of quote dispensing
unquote as well as the vague language
and the disciplinary section of hb1536
while HB 444 includes no definition of
quote dispensing unquote
we have the same problems with its
disciplinary section that we did with
hb1536
for these reasons
we think the timing of HB 444
is premature
until a study is completed
an alternative for the committee to
consider is an amendment being offered
by the New Hampshire Medical Society
which would address the Bill's attempt
to give the Board of Pharmacy too much
authority over other practitioners
including Advanced registered nurse
practitioners
an example is the boards of pharmacies
ability to inspect a nurse's quote
aseptic technique
unquote in non-hospital settings
we see this as an overreach of that
board
and both duplicative and unnecessary
when nurse practitioners are governed by
RSA
326-b and licensed by the Board of
Nursing
we urge the committee to either retain
or amend HB 444
but not to adopt it as introduced
thank you for taking my testimony
thank you are there questions from the
committee
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair and Ms Wilson
thank you for being here today
as you know
I'm not sure anymore whether you were on
the in attendance when the subcommittee
that I was on worked on this compounding
and dispensing issue several years ago I
would say about three or four years ago
were you part of that
gang no it was not okay so so let me
turn on my light so you can see me a
little bit better
um so uh as you know at the time uh
there was a a definite need for uh for
nurses basically that was how it was
being done as I understood it for nurses
to travel out to uh to the homes of
people who are were because of age or
infirmity unable to uh to go into uh one
of these uh centers such as there is uh
very close to the Portsmouth Regional
hospital they have a it was it's called
infusions a fusion Center I think okay
you familiar with that
yes
that service okay so you know that uh
you know that people go in and get their
infusions done there but there are
people who are as I say by virtue of
their infirmity or age or combination
thereof unable to to go to such a center
and they need to be cared for at home uh
and Specialty trained nurses are going
out to these homes uh and there the
question becomes
can they get a sterile a setup so that
they can combine the uh the the
excuse me I've muted you your question
is interesting but it is totally
irrelevant to this bill there is nothing
about infusion or Safe Handling anywhere
the inspection of users talks about
storage and labeling distribution and
Disposal it does not talk about a septic
technique it does not talk about
infusion all of that process has been
completely removed from this bill so
please ask the question that's relevant
to the bill and some of us and not to
the bills from last year thank you very
much I'm sorry
well I appreciate your uh you're
pointing this out but the reason I I
give all this is because Miss Wilson
said she was not part of that uh working
group that tried to straighten that
situation out and so I'm wondering
whether we are going to see something
where the the nurses and the pharmacy
board are going to be on the same page
because we should not be uh playing
Solomon here so are what what can you
tell me with regard to the any attempt
to buy your organization to reach uh
meeting of the minds with the pharmacist
on this issue
well uh I I maintain that
that as representative of the of the
association we maintain that
um each board is responsible for
um
making sure that the rules are in place
the people that they're that people who
are licensed by that board
uh our competent and are following the
rules and uh
I uh as far as
I mean collaboration is fine but
um as far as inspecting uh I I do
believe that
um it's important for uh each board to
take care of of that internally
uh follow up
yes
yes thank you madam chair so but the
point is that
respecting the competence of you and
your organization uh this is this is
something that needs to be resolved and
so that's my question is what is being
done to reach a meeting of the mind so
that we have a collaboration of two two
separate entities uh both of which are
highly trained uh and so much Turf
sensitive I understand but we we got to
get a resolution of this
and just putting it off is not it's not
in the best interest of the citizens of
New Hampshire so where are we going with
this
uh I I understand your concern but uh
again we are we are governed by RSA
326-b
uh which gives us our scope of practice
uh each level of nursing has this in
place and uh
our licensure is
um
well governed by
Board of Nursing and I would say that
for the other disciplines as well
so I I I I think the question is is
thank you thank you
I'll see any other questions I'd like to
call
Ellen piranhas
foreign
good afternoon Madam chair and committee
members my name is Helen pravanus and I
am representing the New Hampshire Board
of Pharmacy I am the current president
of the New Hampshire Board of Pharmacy
and we are in favor of House Bill 444
which has been sponsored by
representative Merchant and um massamila
so this bill serves to clarify and
further Define some existing statutes
pertinent to the practice of Pharmacy
and I just want to take just a few
moments to comment on some of these
changes
regarding the collaborative practice
agreements the statue was simplified to
read an agreement between the pharmacist
and the patient's practitioner and not
requiring the
patient signed the agreement but
obviously the patient give consent to
care so just to give you a little bit of
background about how a collaborative
practice agreement works
for example we have several Pharmacists
and Physicians that have collaborative
collaborative practice agreements around
anticoagulant therapy so for example a
patient would come into the pharmacy
they would get their lab work done
a level would be
um attained and based on that level and
based on what the physician would like
the Coumadin levels to be adjusted by
that's what that that pharmacist would
do so that's kind of an example of like
a simple collaborative practice
agreement around a anticoagulant type of
uh of a clinic setting
um regarding inspection and regulation
of certain uses of prescription drugs
again additional verbiage was added
there to adopt and enforce standards to
promote Safe Handling storage labeling
distribution and disposal of
prescriptions and to also report any
infractions again to those responsible
agencies or licensing boards so there's
nothing there um
um to you know talk about as Ms Wilson
said about aseptic technique so there
isn't anything there around that and
again it it really is all about
promoting patient safety
um you know the inspectors go in and you
know take a thorough look as far as you
know the standards that that should be
met when
um you know anything that around
medications right is is involved and
bringing that then to the attention of
that of their of their own boards
um we feel is appropriate and again as
representative mentioned
um you know I've been on the board for
nine years now and you know back in the
day we we were asked to do this by all
of the all of the medical boards they
they wanted our assistance because they
didn't have the capability and
um the people available to do these
inspections for them so they actually
you know asked us to do this
regarding the pharmacy permits again
additional verbiage was added there to
include the permit holder and pharmacist
in charge to have joint and equal
responsibility we really feel that this
is very very important
um there are instances where there are
certain things that are found upon
inspection in the pharmacy where the
pharmacist in charge maybe is you know
trying to get it fixed like for example
the refrigerator isn't at the right
temperature and they have reached out to
possibly their permit holder their
corporate their manager and they are
still not able to get those those
changes they are not able to get a new
refrigerator or get it fixed and so in
the so the way the rules stand now or
the statue stands now the responsibility
is the pharmacist in charge and the
pharmacist in charge is then receiving
that disciplinary action when in fact
their hands are tied and they really
can't can't do as much as
um as they're able to so that's why that
verbiage was added there and
um
and yeah and again I I do want to say
that the Board of Pharmacy again fully
supports this bill and the
um RSA amendments and I thank you very
much for giving me the opportunity to
provide testimony today I also provided
everybody with written testimony to
support what I'm saying today and I
would be happy to answer any questions
that you may have thank you
thank you from our department questions
[Music]
thank you very much
flower back
yes can you hear me now
okay and let me just turn on my video
there we are
thank you madam chair and through you to
the to the members of the committee my
name is Michael Auerbach I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Dental Society the nhgs is opposed to
hb44
the nhds is a Statewide organization
representing over 1100 members of the
dental profession including dentists
dental hygienists dental assistants and
practice managers all of whom operate in
accordance with the laws and rules of
the dental practice act as administered
by the board of dental examiners if a
violation of these laws or rules occurs
the Bode launches a thorough
investigation of the charges including
if necessary an on-site inspection if
disciplinary action is warranted the
accused is given a fair and reasonable
hearing conducted by the board
consisting of dentist hygienists and
others whose expertise in dentistry is
brought to bear
furthermore any dentist who prescribes
medications for patients must maintain
an active DEA license the requirements
for which are updated continuing
education training on the safe storage
handling labeling distribution and
disposal of prescription drugs the DEA
May if warranted conduct inspections and
initiate disciplinary actions for
non-compliance
in fact in light of the opioid crisis
several years ago it was made mandatory
that all dentists as a condition of New
Hampshire State licensure undergo
biennial continuing education on opioids
and other prescription drugs
lastly nhds and the American Dental
Association have in place a number of
relevant parameters such as our Council
on ethics and Council on peer review
which provide another layer of oversight
on a wide range of issues including
prescription protocols
it is the belief of the New Hampshire
Dental Society the hb44 creates an
unnecessary additional layer of
oversight one that is separate and
disconnected from the primary licensing
board for dentistry in New Hampshire Our
concern is that this bill was developed
without the consultation of the board of
dental examiners or any of the other
licensing boards under the oplc
we're also deeply concerned that the
board of pharmacies relative lack of
familiarity with Dentistry May Foster
unwarranted inspections that cause
confusion and fear among patients
we understand that an amendment has been
offered that would be that will exempt
dentists from section two of this bill
the nhgs is in favor of such an
amendment however with regard to the
original Bill we believe that it will
negatively impact Dental practices
across the state we therefore request
that you vote this legislation in
expedient to legislate and as always the
New Hampshire Dental Society is happy to
provide any information and resources
that this committee may need to make an
informed decision thank you and I'll be
happy to take any questions that you may
have thank you Mr Auerbach do I take
your comments to mean that you object to
section
two of the bill on inspections and you
don't care about the rest our biggest
concern right now is the uh is the
addition of additional inspections and
so and oversight over the board of
dental examiners and the dentists
themselves so section two is specific to
that
um as I said I would be in support of
the amendment striking dentist from that
section uh but I I we're all concerned
about the additional layers of oversight
thank you are there any other questions
for Mr aerbeck
thank you very much thank you James
Potter
good afternoon and thank you madam chair
uh in members of the committee for the
record my name is Jim Potter and I serve
as Executive Vice President for the New
Hampshire Medical Society
um as noted earlier Dr David Conway who
is president of the New Hampshire Board
of Medicine was not able to testify due
to an emergency procedure uh however uh
through uh Mike padmore you have
received an email of his written
testimony uh and for the record the
Board of Medicine did vote against this
provision
um last year and again this year
um
the medical society is again strongly
opposing the language in section two of
House Bill 444 that would strengthen the
board of Pharmacy's ability to inspect
ant will other uh licensed providers
from other boards
um so we have sent uh you all hopefully
you've received at a proposed amendment
uh on this proposed amendment this has
been endorsed by the New Hampshire
Medical Society New Hampshire Board of
Medicine the New Hampshire's Nurses
Association of the New Hampshire's New
Hampshire nurse practitioner Association
New Hampshire veterinary medicine
Association and the New Hampshire Dental
Society
specifically to that end
beginning on line eight of Hospital 444
we would ask to strike the words going
to line nine Physicians veterinarians
dentists Advanced registered nurses
Nurse Practitioners physician assistants
and from the bill
um I did hear your other uh discussion
about Xiao versus May and if those
practitioners are struck that it doesn't
matter to us although we have suggested
the the word may rather than shell also
in our Amendment we would add a new
section new section three
that is references uh uh uh section 318
9-a Inspection Services this this
actually was part of HB 1536 last year
and what it says is that the Board of
Pharmacy then we strike shall and add
May a provide inspectional services
under the Chamber of rsna 18 318 B25 to
the Board of Medicine the board of
veterinary medicine the board of
Podiatry the board of registration for
in Optima in Optometry the board of
dental examiners the Board of Nursing
and the naturopathic Board of examiners
and it would add the words or other
health professional licensing boards
upon the request of the respective board
so again it's very clear
um enough is enough this has been
happening for years for the last five
years
um uh and essentially we're asking that
these professions be removed from any
complicit complied Authority uh from the
Board of Pharmacy
it also clarifies that the New Hampshire
health care professional boards retain
the authority of their respective
licensees request
search inspection services of the Board
of Pharmacy and we believe firmly that's
the way it should be not the other way
around
now normally we would ask you just to
itl this bill but because of the
repeated behaviors
of of
stemming from the Board of Pharmacy over
the last five five years enough is
enough all five professional groups are
requesting to be removed from
inspections and equal employer and
clarify that the respective licenses
boards have clear jurisdiction are able
to re request such Inspection Services
if warranted
further
um I think it's been misrepresented on
the mous in fact the Board of Medicine
last year rejected mou that was put
forward by the Board of Pharmacy to
accomplish this same end it is my
understanding that the Board of Nursing
also rejected a similar mou by the Board
of Pharmacy so as
last year you are on clear record that
both these boards want nothing to do
with the Board of Pharmacy inspecting
their licensees not the other way around
estimated care price today
second this past year the executive
director of The Board of Pharmacy was
terminated due to high uh irregular
activities and practices that stem from
many of the happenings that we're
talking about today and date back a few
years
third not once but twice attempted Rules
by the board Pharmacy have been thwarted
one could say by the lack of authority
but again we didn't think they were
appropriate
um and they were opposed by many boards
and practitioners and fourth house was
referred to earlier uh it troubled me to
hear
um the author say that Remicade uh is uh
is compounded Remicade is not compounded
it is mixed and that was the clear
intent of Senate Bill 581 that was
passed by the general uh General Court
um that essentially restricted the board
of pharmacies authority over compounding
and clarified that infusion products are
not compounded in that way has been
described
right this was stemming from the
previous year when the Board of Pharmacy
went and uh inspected and fined 12
inspection fusion therapy practices and
Clinics
also I'm very troubled by section three
compounding standards of Hospital 444
that would give the Board of Pharmacy
the ability to interpret and issue rules
on National compounding standards
given its more checkered history of
infusion therapy services we would urge
the committee not to make any changes to
the board of pharmacies authority to
develop new rules over prescription
drugs until the oplc's legislative
budget assistant LBA audit is conducted
I've been told that this LBA audit is
scheduled for later this spring and will
be and be focusing on the questionable
practices of the Board of Pharmacy over
the last five years again we're highly
troubled I will speak to one area
outside of section two that was
described attending does not imply being
a PCP or a specialist in fact attending
refers to the patient it is the
intending physician to the patient not
the type of practice so again to clarify
that dialogue I don't think that was
correct and where that was headed again
we're very concerned because we think
this is being used to uh for coercive
inspections to disrupt the marketplace
sending patients to much more expensive
settings and for that we oppose
um the the bill as presented
um ask that you adopt uh our proposed
amendment thank you very much for your
time I'm happy to answer any questions
you might have
thank you Mr Potter can you answer
questions
representative
thank you madam chair uh thank you Mr
Potter you mentioned that
um you would prefer that the various
boards could request are all say
practitioners under the boards could
request an inspection from the Board of
Pharmacy could you give us an example of
for example when a physician's office
would request an inspection by the board
see yeah uh right well let me clarify it
would actually be the respective Boards
of the licensing so it wouldn't be
necessarily an office
it would be a board who would hand a
particular case and say Well we'd like a
little bit more expertise of a uh
inspector who has background in Pharmacy
um and the way that the oplc is
reorganizing its inspectors is actually
not to a specific board but their intent
is to have that you have a group of
inspectors that have various expertises
I think that's where we've gotten in
troubles before is that certain boards
have said uh these are inspectors and we
got to keep them busy and so we're going
to go forward so in this case the intent
of the amendment is really to say that
if the board is presented with a case or
complaint and says we need a little bit
more expertise in this specific case we
can ask the Board of Pharmacy or that
that actually it will be the board of
pharmacies inspector or who has that
that expertise to come in and to do a
further inspection
um excuse me follow-up
so
um a request for someone with further
expertise for inspection would simply be
based on a complaint that that board had
received is that what I'm understanding
not necessarily
um boards investigate various practices
uh the trends you can emanate from a
complaint but the disciplinary practices
are not limited do those kind of
activities so I know it's not based
strictly like to answer your question
thank you madam chair I have no further
question
are there other questions to Mr Potter
thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
on House Bill 444
seeing none
and open the public hearing on our last
build house bill 405.
I don't see the sponsor
so
[Music]
so representative Blackness would you
introduce this bill
yes I'm sure so this I'm introducing
House Bill 405
relative to out-of-state applicant
occupational graduation licensing or
certification
I really don't
I read through this but I don't have a
lot of uh well we already saw I really
can't answer questions
thank you very much
um
the only other the only person who has
signed up to speak is Mr Ross Connolly
so I'm Madam chair can you hear me yes
fine
great well thank you for having me uh
today and thank you to the members of
the committee for holding this hearing
uh for the record my name is Ross
Connolly I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity in New
Hampshire and on behalf of the thousands
of AFP activists across the state I urge
you to support HB 405. while AFP
believes the most effective form of
recognition is to remove unnecessary
government licensing requirements within
New Hampshire so that formal recognition
would not be required in many instances
this bill would at least give relief for
many looking to move to New Hampshire
and work within a licensed field
this licensing recognition bill would
reduce reduce barriers to dozens of
occupations between New Hampshire and
the rest of the country ultimate
ultimately making New Hampshire a leader
in removing Interstate licensing
barriers
many low-income licensed professions
have standards and requirements That
Vary drastically across States we found
this was the case for health care
workers when the state had to quickly
increase the available capacity in the
health care sector during the outbreak
of the covid pandemic Governor sununu
quickly provided Universal recognition
uh for all Health Care sector licensed
workers
so you may ask who who would benefit
from this bill looking across license
Fields uh low-income professions across
New England there are more than a dozen
examples of license requirements that
are more onerous than New Hampshire and
should be automatically recognized
for example
in Rhode Island which is one of the most
onerously licensed states in the nation
uh the the license requirement for being
a shampooer is 1500 hours and in
Massachusetts it's a thousand hours
which is the same as the license
requirement to be a barber in New
Hampshire and here we require a fraction
of the time for shampoors requiring 150
hours
another example if you are an optician
in Massachusetts you are required to
have two years of formal education pass
three exams for a total of an estimated
730 lost days to acquire the license
in New Hampshire we require a hundred
and ten dollar fee and to pass an exam
the Hoops associated with quickly
transferring your optician license have
been waived via emergency order number
39 but that's only temporary New
Hampshire should codify this recognition
and statute by passing HB 405.
and this disparity even exists when it
comes to already widely standardized
licenses we are in the midst of a severe
housing shortage electricians are
desperately needed the national
electrical reciprocal Alliance which New
Hampshire joined in 2005 only applies to
10 states in our bordering states of
Maine Vermont and Massachusetts many of
these highly burdensome states which
also have uh the the highest out by
outbound migration are not included in
our reciprocity so New York Rhode Island
California Pennsylvania New Jersey are
just a few examples of States who do not
have reciprocal policy for electricians
and passing if New Hampshire passes HP
405 it would assist in the effort to
gain more affordable housing
and the last comparison I will give out
of interest of time is truck drivers
this industry has been deemed one of the
most essential during the coveted
pandemic they have rightly so been
viewed as Heroes keeping our shelves
stocked in grocery stores and feeding
America through very difficult times
if you're a truck driver based in New
Hampshire we only require an 80 fee for
the license if you have if you have
passed the proper exams
however if you are in Rhode Island the
requirements include two years of
education passing five exams and losing
an estimated of 730 days in order to
become a tractor trailer driver
any truck driver uh moving to Rhode
Island uh moving from Rhode Island to
New Hampshire has already jumped through
significantly more burdensome
regulations and we should welcome them
by eliminating any additional regulatory
Hoops so that they can quickly begin
contributing to New Hampshire
communities
and just lastly New Hampshire requires a
license for at least a dozen low-income
occupations including some of those I
have already discussed that have uh that
more than half the country does not
require a license for so if an optician
or a sign language interpreter that has
worked in the field in another state for
years and years wants to wants to move
to New Hampshire and and work here HB
405 will allow those who have experience
and can prove that experience to cut the
red red tape that may be holding them
back from working in their field in the
granite state or even moving here simply
because their home state did not require
a license
in the current economy we as a state
should be doing everything possible to
welcome people from out of state who
wish to move here and contribute to our
communities as I've outlined Most states
of higher licensure requirements than
New Hampshire and thus a risk to Public
Safety would be low for all these
reasons we urge you to support HB 405 to
give this this needed regulatory relief
to New Hampshire's employers and
employees and with that I'd be happy to
take any questions
representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair uh thank you Mr
Conley for taking a question in your
example you mentioned truck drivers and
I would like to hear a little bit more
about that because
did when you get your commercial
driver's license that is a state
standard yes but the state has adopted
CFR chapter 90 from the Federal
Regulation uh Federal standards of
Department of Transportation so there is
already a reciprocity in the whole
United States as far as the commercial
truck driver am I correct
uh thank you representative for the
question you are correct there are
federal standards for a lot of these
licenses as well
um what I was specifically pointing to
was the state uh the state requirements
in order to obtain uh the license to be
there's a designation for truck driver
there's a designation for tractor
trailer truck driver uh both in New
Hampshire and in Rhode Island and there
are requirements at the state level uh
in order to obtain those the the
requirements in Rhode Island are
obviously significantly higher uh than
in New Hampshire but they do have
reciprocity when it comes to having like
a CDL you know Federal type uh type
license
okay follow up if I may
Madam chair
yeah
are you sure I didn't make my comment is
not to argue but it is my opinion a bad
example because when you do get your dot
it's one D.O.T license what you do is
you get certain uh you apply to uh you
know such as air brakes so there is a
difference uh you do uh to get your
license to get whether you could drive a
tanker or just a cargo vehicle and
that's all done by the federal standards
so uh New Hampshire is just the same as
Hawaii when it comes down in that
example and would that not be true even
with electrician and meeting the
standards so the NFPA fire code
uh thank you for the the question
representative uh yes that is correct
again there are federal electric
standards and there is vast uh
standardization obviously it's it's the
same electrical code
um in in Most states however to in order
to quickly transfer your license if you
are in the state of say New York or New
Jersey uh you have to completely reapply
for the license and and there's a lot of
of regulations that that are holding
people back I've I just researching some
of this bill talking to to electricians
they that uh they do have difficulty
moving from state to state if you're not
within that that compact that already
exists so this bill would just simply
make it easier for the rest of the
people moving from especially those High
migration States
um who are moving to New Hampshire as we
know to just make that a little a little
easier uh for for that to be able to
quickly start uh start working here
thank you Mr Colleen thank you madam
chair
are there other questions
all right
on that case thank you uh Mr Connolly I
called Tom Broderick
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee can you hear me
yes okay
um for the record I'm Tom Broderick
legal counsel of the office of
professional licensure and certification
or oplc
the oplc provides administrative and
clerical Support record-keeping Services
in business processing for the 54
occupational licensing boards commission
commissions and councils under its
umbrella
so while HP 405 affects all the
professions or or nearly all the
professions and thus all almost all the
boards under oplc's umbrella and I want
to be clear that I'm speaking today on
behalf of the oplc the agency only I'm
not speaking on behalf of the boards I
haven't been authorized to speak on the
half of the boards uh so first I'd like
to thank the sponsor this bill the
intention behind this bill is admirable
and I I want to be clear that oplc does
not oppose reciprocity and making it
easier for those individuals originally
licensed in other states to come work
here
um we have been working on some other
bills uh to join compacts
and and
other things to make it easy to work
here but there are several issues with
this bill some minor some more major
that oplc does have issues with and for
that reason we do oppose the bill is
drafted
so if the committee wouldn't will
indulge for a few minutes oplc's
specific issues with this bill are as
follows
on page one lines 19-20 this is a change
to the qualifications for those applying
for a temporary license from the oplc
currently individuals must certify that
they've committed no Acts or emissions
which are grounds for disciplinary
action in in the jurisdiction they're
coming from
this bill would change it and limit this
to only Acts or missions that are
grounds for discipline in that
jurisdiction quote as negligence or
intentional misconduct related to the
person's profession
our position is this change is
unnecessary and too limiting for
instance what about gross negligence or
Reckless conduct uh also there's a
question as to when
um when an act is quote related to the
person's profession and what really
qualifies here
um clearly if an applicant for an
accounting license has been convicted of
embezzlement that would apply but if I'm
I'm applying for a temporary permit to
become a barber and I have a conviction
for assault in another jurisdiction is
that conviction for assault related to
my profession
um
it's it's just not clear
uh the second
part
um page one lines 25 through 26 has the
same issue with the terms related to the
person's profession it's it's just not
clear
um page one lines 26 through 29
so this is the portion of the bill that
states and I'm paraphrasing that if an
applicant has a complaint pending
against them in another jurisdiction the
oplc and the respective board shall
suspend the application and may not
issue or deny the license until the
complaint is resolved I I understand the
intent behind this but this is again in
conflict with uh RSA
541a29a which states and I paraphrase
again that the boards must rule on an
application within 60 days of receipt of
that the completed application or else
the application is deemed granted as a
matter of law so um this conflict would
need to be resolved in some way if this
bill were passed
the next uh issue
on page two lines 17-25 this is the
portion of the bill that would require a
board to issue a license to someone
based on work experience in another
state if their home state doesn't
license that profession they've worked
for three years in that occupation and
they meet certain other requirements
so there's several issues with this the
the the smaller issue is on line 24. um
they have to verify that they've worked
in their profession in that home state
for three years uh I I'm not sure how
oplc can verify this if they're not
licensed in their home state I suppose
we would be
um
basically trusting them when they say
that they have have worked in that
profession for for three years but the
larger issue is one we testified to on a
similar Bill last legislative session
um I'm not sure how to phrase this I'm
just going to call it unintended
consequences
um naturopathic doctors are the prime
example here there may be others though
we do that we don't know about
so not all states regulate naturopathic
doctrines 18 states and U.S territories
do New Hampshire is one of them and in
New Hampshire naturopaths may actually
may prescribe medications according to
the naturopathic formulary which is set
by the naturopathic board so if this
bill is passed we could have the
situation where someone from a state
that does not license naturopaths could
open a business there hang out a shingle
call themselves a naturopath
um
with little or no training they could
practice in that state for three years
moved to New Hampshire and then get a
license under this provision that
individual would then according to state
law have the ability to prescribe
medications to the public with no
training so oplc does have concerns
about that
um as I said there may be other
professions with similar concerns I just
don't know and it would take an
extensive review of other states
licensing schemes What professions those
States license and the Scopes of
practice of
um various uh State Licensing schemes
um the next concern so that's I think
that's the biggest concern the next
concern page two lines 26 through Page
Three line two so this is the portion of
the bill that would require a board to
issue a license to someone who holds a
private certification if their home
state doesn't license that profession
they worked for two years in that
profession and they hold a private
certification in our in good standing
with that certifying body and I meet a
few other requirements so this is
another route for those seeking
licensure that are coming from another
state that doesn't regulate that
profession only now they can get a
license I see it as similar to the
previous but now they can get a license
after two years based on a private
certification rather than the three in
the previous subsection
so oplc's same concerns apply here
um first how do we verify that they've
worked in that profession for the two
years and second the larger issue of
unforeseen consequences which I
explained in the example of the
naturopathic doctors
but the other concern here is with these
private certifying bodies
um I want to be clear many outside
certified bodies are excellent and many
of our boards rely on either private
certifications to some extent or tests
that were developed by these outside
certifying groups but the fact of the
matter is
anyone can start a non-governmental
certifying body and the state has no
control over the qualifications that the
certifying body would require
um so you know what would stop a
unscrupulous individual from creating
um I guess I could call it a sort of
diploma Mill but for private
certifications
um lastly I just want to point out that
the truck driver example
um I believe this is a change to RSA 332
G14
um RSA chapter 332g applies only to
title 30 of the rsas
um so it's only the professions that
where their practice acts excuse me
practice practice acts uh are located in
title 30. I don't believe truck drivers
are in there
um I think 95 of oplc boards are in
there a few are not
um and then there's a few oplc boards
that are in other provisions of of the
rsas
um I don't have any more testimony I
thank you for your time I'm happy to
take any questions
thank you Mr Brown uh representative
Pearson
thank you
I'm going to start by saying uh not I
don't have an opinion on this bill yet
but the
Mr Roderick the more you spoke the more
questions
I have
you talked about on specifically page
124 lines 24 of that section and you
talked about the conflict with RSA 541a
with the 60 days of receipt requirement
there are there are other areas in
statute that have time frames like that
and typically what it's done is that you
know you are required to to do something
within the 60 days and typically that's
just a rule they rejected to give
themselves an extension
so
is that an Avenue that can be done
as to alleviate the concern of that 60
days when it comes to folks that have a
pending investigation
would you believe that that issue could
be resolved by adding
um
you know perhaps
beginning of that sentence line 26 uh
before if an applicant if you could say
notwithstanding RSA 541a 29a that would
alleviate
oplc is concern that specific concern
okay the other part the other question I
have is there's something you just
talked about here on on page two at the
bottom of the private certifications
uh I I agree I very much agree with your
assessment of of what what a private
certification
actually truly is do you at the current
time does the oplc have a
list a database an idea as to what
private certification organizations are
accepted by the otlc versus ones that
are not
um
so
right now uh right now oplc we we can't
we can't issue a license on the basis of
a certification only I guess what I
meant by that is
um
some boards in their practice acts uh
specifically say
um like for instance the speech language
pathology board
um says one of their requirements for
licensure is it that you have
certification from Asha which is the
association of speech hearing I'm
butchering it but
um an outside certifying body it's a
national body there is a way around that
you can if you're not a member of Asha
you can take another route but so
there's examples where it's in statutes
there's also examples where boards
through rules have said
um as proof of your educational
experience and experience we will accept
your membership into
um X
certifying organization
I I don't have a comprehensive list it
would be in all the board statues it
would be board specific and you'd go in
the board statutes and rules so what a
fix to this then necessarily work if it
said a private certification
organization recognized by the oplc
um
that way those that are not recognized
are are not deemed applicable in those
that the oplc has already vetted and
said yes we do recognize that this
private certification organization does
bring something of value to the table
and and we hold that certification
as being something of validity for what
you know for moving forward
that would alleviate some of the
concerns I I can't speak for the boards
as I had said in the beginning I mean
the boards of the the experts on the
profession rather than the
administration
um so we would have to be doing that in
consultation with the boards
um
so that would require oplc keeping a
list of what would be acceptable what
certifying body would be acceptable for
each profession
and the boards would have to determine
within each board what they I understand
your management part of it each of the
of the 54 boards would have to
decide as a board what they would accept
as a private certification or not
correct correct if if the legislature
were going to go that way I would
suggest
um that that decision should be made by
the boards as they are the experts in in
that profession
representative
thank you madam chair
um good afternoon Mr Broderick
um I'm curious
um if this bill were to pass would you
say that this would
um be much more burdensome time wise to
the various Boards of oplc then your
current methods for recipe
um
well I would
I I'm not exactly sure how to answer
that it it would add two more as I read
it two more
um avenues for reciprocal licensing
um and uh
right now I don't know if this is
answering your question so I'm I'm sorry
if it's not right now there are many
avenues for reciprocal licensing but a
lot of it depends on which board they're
applying for
um personally I you know I would love to
see some sort of standardization
um so that there's uh more similarity
process between all the boards
this doesn't get rid of any extraneous
processes it just adds two more so I I
suppose it would take a little more time
answers my question thank you
representative
thank you madam chair
good afternoon Mr Broderick
um I
um am concerned about this bill because
I think that to give wide life you know
expand the licensing in this manner may
have unintended consequences based on
the profession that's involved and our
current
the way we currently do this now in my
limited experience with Edna has been to
address reciprocity on a professional on
a profession basis with this with a
certain board
because at that time the boy can decide
for itself what they're going to
recognize that as the qualification
whether it be private certification or
um work experience
so how and and so my question to you is
is that not
um from an opioids oplc management
standpoint considering your position
versus the Board is it not easier and
more unless
um
and a path of having less unattended
consequences to continue in the way this
this has addressed reciprocity
the board themselves and the profession
um
yes I mean to your point and I I think
rewarding a point from pre
repoint previous excuse me a point I
made previously the uh you know we
licensed 54 different professions they
all have and I know bits and pieces of
each profession and so do the staff that
work here but there's no way we know
there's a reason why we have uh
people in the profession on these boards
and that is to determine matters like
this uh yeah
thank you I think you've answered my
question I appreciate it thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you Mr
Broderick for taking my question
uh and looking at this uh
says any person shall have uh worked for
at least three years in a lawful
occupation
doesn't say the number of hours in the
year it just says three years could
three years be I worked one week each
year and that's classified as I was
doing the occupation for three years
um yes
yeah I mean that would be another issue
here
thank you thank you representative
Schmidt
thank you madam chair
turn on my lights so Tom can see me
um so this strikes me as a rowboat with
a lot of little leaks in it
um but uh the question I have is uh do
we have a flood of people coming in from
uh surrounding areas or wherever uh
seeking Licensing in the in the areas
that this bill addresses
and what can you comment on whether we
have whether we actually would be
justified in fixing all each one of
these little leaks uh or any of the
Little leaks for that matter uh with the
staff that you time that you have
available
uh to to meet uh the needs of people who
want to come here and work
thank you representative Schmidt um
I unfortunately I may need to have to
get back to you as legal counsel I don't
see uh the everyday requests that are
coming in for reciprocity I would
probably have to check with our
administrative team
um
so I'm happy to get back
to you with something in writing I I
will know I mean the with the amount of
emergency licenses Etc that we're
issuing under
um covid and the extra pandemic work we
are stretched pretty thin but
um to your specific question of how
um how many individuals this would uh
help I'm happy to talk with my executive
director and more the administrative arm
and get some of that for you
uh follow-up follow-up
so you have I mean you you've got enough
work to to fill out your day I'm sure
and just all the aspects that you've
addressed in in this bill show uh a
command of the uh the the subject
material that you deal with on a regular
basis uh because as I said this is a
book with a lot of little leaks
um and ultimately uh it it all has to be
fixed because we we can't have
half of it and and not the other half
that that's not the kind of Bill we want
to pass in this committee so uh I I'm
not sure how quickly we have to act on
the bill uh the chair can speak to that
but but uh as I say
this is a it would be a lot of work for
the agency to uh to to get at if
there's not a lot of people uh waiting
in any one of these professions to come
into New Hampshire from surrounding
areas
um so I think I think it needs a lot
more work before we could think of
acting on it
I have a question Mr Broderick that you
I hope you would look into
sure some years ago we passed a
requirement that asked the boards to
post what states had equivalent
requirements because most of the
practice acts say that they shall
license people from states with
equivalent requirements and at
two years after that law passed I had I
saw no such listings and I would hope
that if you could find out if any of the
boards have bothered to put up
say
the state of Massachusetts is fine the
state of Maine is inadequate because of
this or whatever
the the issue is because that sort of
information that the board should know
from the licenses that and request for
reciprocity that they received and they
should make it public
so I hope it could you find out which if
any boards have done something like that
sure I do know that our boards have a I
think each board has a like reciprocity
tab on our website but
um I can find out what's posted on that
tab
um and yes I can get that information
thank you and I would mention that I
know someone from Washington State
ring to moving
is a licensed electrician in Washington
and he had the requisite apprenticeship
including 8 000 hours of supervised
practice which is the same requirement
we have here and he was told that if you
were to come to New Hampshire you would
have to repeat that eight thousand
dollars rather than being able to
transfer his journeyman's license
and that's something that is totally
unacceptable as far as I'm concerned
of course that's third hand verbal I
didn't speak to the electricians board
myself but if
if that's the kind of response we're
giving to people who are thinking of
moving to this area and they call up the
board and say hey I'm a licensed
electrician what do I need to do to get
a license and they're told they have to
start 40 four or five years back
that's a very bad problem we have and
I'm sure this bill is intended to
address that
end of speech
all right are there any other questions
for Mr Broderick
okay seeing none is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on House Bill 405
all right seeing none thank you Mr
Broderick and uh
close the hearing on how to spell 405.
correct okay
all right
um
it is
3 35. I think we will take a 10 minute
break and then come back and resume with
the executive session on house bills 274
and 591.
probably 591 first
foreign
[Music]
just so you know I muted the committee
room and um just you'll need to unmute
when you're ready to resume thanks
foreign
the whole time
afternoon everyone
thank you all for lasting through a
day that's finished better than it
started
all right on House Bill 274.
we
amended it with
uh
representative of brahmi's amendment
that clarified the fee section
both representative blackis and
representative schuette have submitted
amendments where that part is identical
the only question chair yes
excuse me you mentioned House Bill 274
believe you're referring to House Bill
you are totally correct I apologize
you're absolutely right house bill 591
The Liquor Commission
thank you the
the difference between the amendment we
have already adopted
the shoe would have been and the Lexus
Amendment it are only in the last
section about the two positions so I
think
the simplest way to handle it will be to
debate what we want to do with the two
positions whether to delete them
completely whether to leave them as our
last amendment was as as examiners or
change them as the Seward Amendment
calls for into investigators
and then
pass the appropriate Amendment so that
we only have one amendment to deal with
Miss Sparling begged me to make sure we
only passed one Amendment so I will I
will do issue requests thank you very
much
of course that would mean you know
unless you pass
um0116 the abrami amendment you'd need
to reconsider and and turn it down since
you once you have
decided what we want to do what we can
make sure to adopt the amendment that
does what we want right
so
uh
under the circumstances I'd like to ask
representative shuitt to briefly explain
why she wants to change the examiners we
had in our current Amendment
to inspectors and then I'll ask
representative leckis to explain why he
wants to eliminate the positions and
then open it up for debate
okay
sounds like a plan okay I am go ahead
I thank you madam chair uh yes I my
amendment was drafted so that
technically
the amendment that the committee has
already adopted which changed the fee
structure would still be in place and
basically putting it back to the
original bill that called for to
investigators
as folks may recall during the
questioning of the chief of the
inspection officers
um he indicated that yes he could use
two more investigators uh the numbers
that they gave us uh the fact that there
are approximately
5600 facilities
and with 15 investigators uh that looked
about a ratio of one investigator for
every
375 facilities which means that
and ratio the investigators could
probably get to one facility a year
each facility once a year let me put it
that way
so it struck me that it was likely that
um they could use two more investigators
we heard that examiners if they found
something
egregious
would have to then call for an
enforcement officer I hope that you have
all seen the email from Lieutenant
Morrison a former investigator
um to the need for uh having an
investigator rather than an examiner do
this kind of work he felt that it would
actually be more efficient
and so on that basis that's why I am
putting this amendment forward to put
those two investigator positions back in
place thank you for the time
um yes I mean
suffered from the changes of Licensing
done in this build or may or may not be
a need for either additional
investigators or examiners
um
I don't know that that should be dealt
with in the same bill
I think the most places that sell
it looks like the effect of this would
be to add some
to have some places that sell alcohol
be able to add tobacco a tobacco license
at a reduced
and
The Whipper tradition is already
reviewing and inspecting the location
that currently has a liquor license I
don't see there would be significantly
more work at the same place
um and so my Amendment would eliminate
the positions would included neither and
uh investigators or examiners
to ask you a question
and that is is it normal to include
positions in statute or is that normally
part of the budget submitted by the
governor
legislature
so it would not have to be done that way
if the Liquor Commission felt that they
needed more positions it could be done
through the normal budget process and
that's what I would suggest should be
done including it kind of almost an
extraneous thing to purpose though
great
thank you representative blackis that
brings us the point of debating these
positions of Representative Allegro I
had a question that uh either of the
amendment sponsors to answer I just want
to be 100 clear on the role of
investigators is it to make regular
annual or semi-annual business or is it
to investigate complaints and then I'll
I may have to follow along please
I can't
the investigators they do both
semi-regular visits
and they also follow up to complaints
okay
so I was just wondering if the concerns
about a ratio or a a once a year visit
um
is is necessarily a concern because
you know that
that's the ratio of investigators to
total number of Institutions but
not necessarily the ratio of
investigators to Total business
we have no data as the number
yes yes okay
um
the more I hear about it the more I am
confused because I have to apply uh
Committee hearing discounts to some of
the things that I hear
I don't know how audits work I don't
know what the investigators do or
Auditors do uh I'm calling it orders or
examiners even you know I have this
conception that an examiner comes in
most of the time it's a routine audit
there's nothing I don't know even what
they do they count liquor bottles do
they look at receipts
once in a while they're going to find
somebody that's loading up their trunk
or selling it or do and I'm all of a
sudden
not understanding and not in a position
to understand
and what this says to me is this is not
our area of expertise this may be a
great idea but I don't know that I think
this should be split off in Ways and
Means ought to be looking at this
because they deal with Liquors uh all
the time I have liquor around Christmas
so that's I I I it isn't that I'm a
I'm opposed to this bill be that portion
of the bill being here it may be a
wonderful life I've said it
okay I'm going to be calling on people
in the order that they have not yet
spoken today so representative Fontenot
thank you thank you uh Madam chair
um a short follow-up on representative
scitec's point about the examiners I'm
not sure
um if the examiner position exists at at
this point
um or if the look commission at Liquor
Commission has exclusively
investigators and and that it was this
bill that was going to then create these
two examiner uh positions and and if
those positions are adequately defined
I don't recall that testimony
thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair and I too am I
will support uh representative schwart's
Amendment for
the investigators the original bill was
for investigators not sure I think
whether it was just cost savings uh
looking to get positions to go to
examiners but also want to just remind
folks that during the testimony we did
here from
the department that uh businesses out
there
the feedback from them on the uh
individuals going in and helping out in
the workplace uh with uh rules and laws
and regulations was positive and that
they were receiving positive feedback on
their employees
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so I have a being
neither a smoker nor a drinker I haven't
been in the New Hampshire liquor store
or any liquor store for I don't know a
couple of years
um uh so my first question is excuse me
do the investigators
uh can they deal with cigarette issues
or tobacco issues as well as liquor
issues yes
okay that was my assumption so
I think if first of all if we are going
to go for personnel at all we ought to
go to investigate go for investigators
they are the more useful and and
valuable employees to have for the
Liquor Commission
um so the question for me only becomes
whether we want to uh well see whether
we have a majority for investigators and
then whether we want to go forward with
adding positions at all
thank you uh representative
thank you madam chair
um I just wanted to
um look me back in my notes the
um this bill is going to mean Ways and
Means after it goes it comes here after
it leaves here excuse me and um the way
we had someone named Mark
I'm sorry I cannot pronounce his name
he said that applications have gone up
through by 167
in the um liquor uh license area that
includes smoke shops there's 5
661 active licenses and they have 26
investigators some are full-time and
some are part-time and each investigator
in has approximately 377 licenses that
they're responsible for
um it was also noted by the um
representative abrami that these two
investigators would be sworn officers
and they would be paid in time by the
fees collected from this change in fee
schedule
um let me just see what other thing that
I can say to be helpful
um we also um Catherine Frey from new
Futures also testified in favor of the
in support of the bill because she felt
the enforcement which I guess is part of
the investigator's role would help with
those who are younger than 21 years old
um the uh Arden Moore who's the state
liquor commissioner also uh testified
and
um he was supportive of the amendment
especially with the um
the fee remedy
so that I hope that helps but it seemed
to me that the um that most people that
testified were in support of the
investigators because of the workload
and the enforcement regulations that are
needed in this industry
thank you
representative fellows
thank you madam chair
um I was having I've had this sense that
one of the concerns might be the cost of
these two positions so I looked up
um the Personnel classifications for
these jobs and the investigators which
are the lower level
um which are the higher position their
labor grades there's two classes a one
and a two and those are labor grades 19
and 20.
and the examiners there are three levels
17 20 and 23
. so there's and these are not high
level positions the classified labor
grades I've seen the lowest one I've
ever seen was eight and the highest you
can get is 35 and that's somebody who
usually supervises
um quite a few people
so I don't think that the cost is really
an issue on this if if that's what's
been holding some people back so I
certainly
um support the investigators I also
looked at the job description
descriptions and
um the investigators the job description
was last updated in 2017 the other ones
were last updated in 2010 which it
doesn't prove but it um
in a way supports the representative
fontenotes thought that perhaps
um nobody they don't even employ any of
that position at the moment
so that's what I have to say all right
representative
thank you madam chair
um representative in a couple of my
points that the bill will bring on to
Ways and Means I just wanted to respond
to representative scitec's concerns that
my main intent is that we would just be
endorsing the policy of adding these two
positions
and of course Ways and Means would make
the final decision as to the economics
of thank you
I have a question for representative
yes
I representative so just just so I heard
you right the pay grade for an
investigator is 19 and 20 The Examiner
is 17 20 23 the examiners have a higher
pay grade than the investigators
potentially
um at the top level I mean I'm just I'm
just reading from the database that has
all the job descriptions and
classifications that's not telling you
if anybody's in that slot but that's
correct those are the labor grades
and they're not those are not high labor
grades right no right
[Music]
I guess my presumption with the
investigation repeat more than examiners
but I guess that's not the case
it may be the higher ones
very likely uh I would like to mention
that at the hearing that representative
abrami mentioned that the amendment that
eliminated the duplicate license fees
for tobacco plus alcohol places which is
a lot of them would
in fact make it unlikely that the fees
collected would cover the cost of the
Auditors but that's
we don't know that for sure we don't
know what their their budget is like and
I think that's something that Ways and
Means and finance need to work out
so representative Allegro yeah I didn't
want to chime in again but I I asked the
question of what investigators do versus
examiners
and we're sitting here debating whether
or not we're going to
essentially authorize two employees
or to employee classes one of two
employee classes neither of which any of
us appears to know what their function
is
so maybe we should consider holding off
on this one until we know precisely what
those roles are excuse me the sun is in
my eyes I can't
um you can't see the screen but maybe we
should hold off until we've
understood what an investigator what an
examiner does what their paid rates are
whether that's
even a concern
just a thought
[Music]
um
I'm new to the committee but it seemed a
little strange to me that this bill came
to Union in the first place
and certainly strange that we would be
deciding whether or not to have
positions and what type is
previous speaker said you know that we
don't fully understand and that's part
of why
I have the amendment to remove them all
together and if Ways and Means feels
there is a need
to add them they can do that either this
bill or someplace else that's what I
would suggest doing yeah the
uh the positions could be easily added
in this in the budget
if they are deemed to be appropriate but
as you say we don't know what these
people do
and we don't know what they
so we don't know the really the
difference between the two positions
very well at all
and
um and we also you know have it as far
as I know
uh seriously analyze the actual needs of
of a Liquor Commission and if you have
any understanding of whether they really
do need these positions
it's very quickly to Representatives
show it you mentioned that we were the
policy committee and that Ways and Means
would do the dollars and cents of it and
I think they really I don't want to be
trying to be Mr last word but I think
it's really a policy decision for them
if they if they want the two invest if
if you can sell the two investigators to
them I'll vote for it but right now I I
I'm going to Kick the Can up the road or
down the road wherever the road is
I'm not at all sure why we got this bill
in the first place
fees belong with toys and means and
commerce normally deals with the details
of the Liquor Commission and the
licenses we don't
this is totally outside of our bail of
wind and none of us are familiar with
the type of
of issues that are brought out and
if we were in a normal year where we
could where we were meeting in session I
would have asked to vacate this bill
because it's not really appropriate for
us
so
I agree that we should
pass pass to get the fee changes that
representative abrami says correct a
mistake and everybody seems to worry
about that but I'm not personally
comfortable with adding new positions
when we
didn't really get the good understanding
of what they do or why we need them
okay representative goalie has a comment
thank you madam chair and all the
discussion about not knowing what these
folks do I thought it was explained to
us uh in the hearing that
um the examiners do the auditing and
looking at the records where the
investigators have the enforcement
Authority
so I'm not sure where we're not
knowing what they do because for my
recollection that was explained to us
from the Department in the hearing
thank you I'm glad you got it so could
you explain it to me
I thought I just did that the examiners
were the ones that do the auditing and
looking at the records and receipts and
my understanding was the investigators
uh actually had the law enforcement
authority to actually
follow up on the cases and prosecute
them
thank you
um
even if that's true you know we don't
have an overview really of the workload
of the department I don't think police
know how many employees what type they
had or whatever they need
and so I wouldn't feel comfortable
supporting adding positions but I can't
really tell that they really are me
and it's really not I don't see it as
our job to do that
thank you
representative fellows
um yes Madam chair I'm just if you want
me to read a couple of words from the
job descriptions I can or I can
um take me a little bit of time I could
uh email them to you there's five of
them all together if you want to see all
three of the layers but it's very clear
that the examiners I'm just reading
words from the first two items of the
job description
um audits verify sales uh delivery
reports and fiscal audits prepares
reports of tax payments and violations
and the other one
the investigator
um supports
licensing by doing
inspections issuance of new in renewed
licenses and the second item talks about
conducts criminal investigations so
those they always list what the person
does most
at on the first lines of the description
so
thank you
representative schuett you have another
comment
yes um I have known
um a few actual liquor investigators
mostly they are retired police officers
who are familiar with the laws and they
investigate for example charges of
someone who has gotten a DUI who then
they investigate whether or not the
bartender involved for example in a bar
was not following the law about
um
on refusing to serve someone who has
over imbibed things of that nature
um and again I will just say that
basically I put this amendment in to
return the bill to the original way that
we got it except for the um
changes in the tax
ramifications
and that's the way I felt it should go
ways and means I'm sure that the ways
and means members have much more
knowledge of what investigators do and
the implications of this bill
thank you great representative fellows
sorry I thought I put my hand down I did
put my hand down
no it's then you're sorry I lowered my
hand instead of unmuting myself
um
I just want to reiterate that it was
these positions were described in the
hearing and also the need for these
subscriptions these these positions was
also
um requested by not only representative
abrami but by the liquid commission so I
don't um feel comfortable taking them
out of the out of the bill
um
and I would rather I would rather
support
um representative shewitz Amendment
rather than that of Representative
luckis no um no harm intended
all right thank you
very much representative Pearson
I think it's been it's been made Fairly
clear that this is really something that
should be handled by
the other committee
so I'm
I'm fine with the Lexus Amendment let's
get it over to them and let them deal
with the particulars that they're used
to
[Music]
does anyone else
or in
session mode
I do have a quick comment if Ways and
Means finds that these positions are not
necessary then they can take them out is
that correct
yes
okay
um
rather than having a specific vote on
the specific Amendment
I think we have a three Choice vote it's
important to handle it
okay
uh oh I have plenty of papers okay it's
fine so I think we will
the the simplest thing to do is to vote
on whether we think there should be
examiners
inspectors or no Physicians the bill and
then we will adopt the amendment that
identity breaks our will
that's agreeable
shelves wait I I think it's investigator
maybe you said this I mean I couldn't
hear it quite right investigators or
examiners or no position correct I
thought you said inspectors so it's
investigators or examiners correct
okay uh
representative scitec could you call the
role okay
what is
what is the vote
I just believe this bill should be
amended or left alone and whether we
send it forward with investigators
examiners or no positions
right but what are we voting yes or no
are we going to vote investigators or
exams oh no positions investigators or
examiners
she's a three-way vote
this is a survey essentially it's a
survey like a straw poll whatever yeah
after we decide what the committee wants
then we will find the amendment that
that puts that into proper language and
adopted
it's a little unusual yes thank you
okay at this restaurant you have a
choice of three columns investigate them
or Zippo uh representative uh the word
I'm sorry yes zero
a low calorie I'll vote zero on the
grounds and we've talked about
representative Pearson zero
representative yakubovic zero
representative electus zero
representative Allegro zero
representative uh Bailey
zero
representative lanzara
zero representative
zero
representative goalie
investigators
uh representative schuette investigators
representative Judy
foreign
Ute yourself
okay
where is he investigated
yeah
representative uh uh excuse me
show us
investigators
okay well we we know it's
representative Schmidt
investigators
uh representative Schultz
investigators representative fellows
investigators representative Fontenot
investigators representative Grodin
investigators please representative
O'Brien
investigators okay I didn't mean to step
on your line representative Rhoda it
does look like it's quite binary 10 9
10. all right the current status of the
bill is that we adopted an amendment
that put in examiners which
so I did I didn't hear a vote of the
chair
and I didn't hear what the outcome was
excuse me that's correct I wasn't asked
I vote with the zeros so we have nine in
favor investigators 10 in favor of no
positions and nobody wants examiners
well I wouldn't mind
thank you
so so the amendment we previously
adopted has examiners
nobody wants to do that so I would
invite a motion to reconsider our vote
to adopt that Amendment
the only problem is if
don't adopt that Amendment and we want
to adopt my Amendment then we go back to
the whole fees in the original bill
and also if you're a kid you can't do
that because my amendment to set up to
use the section numbers
oh okay so that instead of a complete
Amendment you just have a deleted
positions correct okay so you don't have
to reconsider that but but Madam
chairman you do have Amendment
um0269 which is the fees from the abrami
amendment and contains no positions
no no you did it on your own
you're right that amendment has my name
on it yeah so in any event we want to
reconsider the motion to adopt the the
abrami amendment which nobody wants and
then we can vote on the if we choose to
not adopt that Amendment we can adopt my
Amendment
and have a minority support recommending
the shoe at Amendment which is what it
sounds like
so I will
um
invite a motion to reconsider our vote
the abrami amendment 0116.
so
all right representative Allegro moves
to reconsider
in a second
that
um
Allegro moves to reconsider our motion
our motion to adopt that Amendment and
we will vote on the motion to reconsider
oh one one six yes
so the motion is to reconsider if you
think the amendment 0-116 that we
previously adopted does not reflect the
will of the committee then you will vote
Yes to reconsider if you want to pass
the bill with with that Amendment open
up
representative Werner
is the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes yakubovic representative
yes
I'm sorry representative legis yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
lansara
yes representative Santo nastasso
yes representative goalie
yes
representative
representative Judy
you hear me
okay
uh representative Schmidt
yes yes
representative Schultz
yes
uh representative fellows yes
representative
yes representative Rhoda yes
representative O'Brien yes and this time
the chair yes
19-0 all right
yeah voted to reconsider therefore the
next action is to re-vote the ought to
pass on Amendment 116.
and again this is the corrected license
fees plus the change to uh examiners
thank you
I'm sorry madam chair is this the shoe
Amendment no this is the abrami we voted
to reconsider so now we're reconsidering
okay okay all right I'm so sorry on the
straw poll I would expect everybody to
vote no because nobody wanted this
choice
Madam chair yes
I I need um Pam to send me the
um the amendment that begins with two to
something I have I have like three or
four amendments I don't have the one
that I think is the last most recent one
there are copies in the committee room
just so you for the people there and
I'll send it out to everybody an email
in a sec what is and what's the number
six nine I don't have that one thank you
sure
just just for clarification
exactly okay yes
a yes vote means that you want to adopt
the abrami amendment with the change to
examiners instead of inspectors
so
a no vote means that you are not
satisfied with that Amendment for
whatever reason
so this is the reconsider the motion of
the adopted Amendment 0-116h
is everyone properly confused yes
okay in that case no more than usual
okay
representative order
no
represent the third books no
representative Pearson no representative
yakubovic
no
representative electus so
representative Allegro now
representative Bailey no
representative lanzara
representative Santo nastasso
now
representative goalie
no
representative short
representative Judy
no ah
representative Schmidt no
representative Schultz no
representative fellows
no
representative no no
representative Grodin no representative
O'Brien
no and the chair no
zero to nine all right that mode that
amendment has now failed
the bill is open to further Amendment
representative
I would like to move on to pass or
adoption of amendment 0269h
foreign
okay
that was um
zero two six nine eight
zero two six nine
um
you made this motion representative like
this and who seconded
here
if I I'm sorry I missed on the Zero
nineteen who made the motion and
seconded on that please
uh
at least
did the reconsideration
to reconsider
we just have to move the motion to
reconsider authorization
okay so this is
so the motion pending is uh the
amendment adoption event of
0269h correct which is made by
represents and uh second is Pearson
and as we discussed this amendment has
the same
license fees
stops
so no positions are asked
okay is there any discussion
clarification this is the amendment
where the fee schedule is correct and
there are no positions correct all right
okay okay
there's no further discussion
the clerk will follow the role
Representatives uh Werner
yes
representative Pearson yes
representative yakubovic
yes representative leicus yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
lansara yes representative Santo
nastasso
yes representative goalie
yes no I'm sorry no I understand what's
up you caught me off guard there I
didn't think I was up uh I'll I'll buy
you and representative Schmidt a drink
afterwards I think I miss somebody on
the roll call
uh
I did I called him he said I answered
yes no I did not no no you did not
that's why I was not prepared to answer
that I heard of it I heard him
who didn't hear it
yeah I vote uh yes the representative
goalie has voted no representative show
it
representative schuett votes no
representative Judy
no
representative Schmidt no representative
Schultz no representative fellows
no
representative from no
representative Grodin
no
representative O'Brien no the chair yes
yes
all right
so is there a motion
htl on
you don't have to
move
then I'd like to make a motion off to
pass
as amended on 591
and then and the amendment is the
luckiest Amendment uh no it's Maguire or
manifestation
who just voted on that updates the fees
to the same as the abrami one but
removes the positions
I'm so sorry of course the McGuire
Amendment yes yes yes okay I'm sorry yep
right
uh is there a second
all right representative lectus seconded
by representative Pearson is there any
discussion
yes so now we're voting on the amended
uh yes we're voting on the final
recommendation to the house
they may run out of paper
any further discussion questions
seeing any
motion is about to pass with amendment
of 269 H and the clerk of all the world
representative Warner
yes
representative Pearson yes
representative yakubovic
yes representative electus yes
representative yes representative Bailey
yes representative lanzara yes
representative Santo nastasso
yes
representative goalie
no
representative
no representative Judy
no
representative Schmidt no
representative Schultz
no
representative sellos
representative Fontenot
yes
I'm sorry representative Fontenot yes
representative Rhoda
no
representative O'Brien
I had the chair
yes
[Music]
11.
11 8. the vote is 11 to 8. this will be
a regular calendar bill is there going
to be a Minority Report and who's going
to write it
uh did we get a response yeah yeah see
right the
if there is a Minority Report it's due
to me no later than Monday
all right we will let you know um by the
end of the day
or just send it in I mean it's Thursday
so I just have a question so it'll be
listed with just one Amendment just the
last one is that correct yes the
minority proposes to adopt the bill
ought to pass with the shuet amendment
for example which is certainly a
legitimate position then both amendments
will be listed in the calendar
thank you
all right moving right along
the house bill 274.
the
when we left off the last time the
motion of itl failed
representative Pearson
I have an amendment to bring forward
exhaust and I present Amendment
0295 each
what this amendment does is this is
I'm sorry this is just I don't have a
copy this is removed
okay representative Pearson
thank you uh what the amendment does
here is the amendment changes this bill
to remove group one out of it if you
turn to uh in the bill and it leaves it
at the five percent as originally
written
so if you were looking at the
fiscal note group one which is the
reason they didn't add a new fiscal
notice because it just eliminates group
one so the fiscal notification would
still be applicable and appropriate
may I ask a question
uh yes
so what you're saying is that
only the contributions to group one
we cut would be paid five percent of
that would be paid by
state
and then the teachers which is group two
I got this backwards do I have it
backwards
yes okay so group one okay group one
that teaches with paper state but then
the fire department and police
department would all stay still the
responsibility of the municipalities is
that what you're saying
so the five percent State contribution
would would kick in for police and fire
yeah
group one the teachers would stay as
they are today with no change and why is
that
the the reason for that really honestly
has to do with what I what I have
personally witnessed in the last four
years of municipalities
tightening their belts and
some reorganization especially with the
expanded roles that police and fire fed
during the pandemic and what I have seen
from the group one is the exact opposite
so
there comes a point in time where we
continue to
give money
to
to group one in essence to the to the to
education and for every dollar the state
seems to give them they want a dollar
25. and I I am
I'm literally just kind of at wit's end
with the lack of fiscal restraint that's
going on I am I'm just really not
interested in providing
any more dollars in that Avenue until I
can see some sort of willingness on the
part of the school districts to do what
everybody else in the town side of
government has done and that is really
look at things and do what's necessary
to live within their means
the fire department as an example
and how they didn't want to pay for
other people's fire department and
police department
so again I go back to We Are One
community
and you have the feeling of unrestraint
budget expansion by the school on your
part
Maybe
has is not may not be based on data
because it's certainly not true in my
school district
and many school districts on the
Seacoast so I'm I'm I I am very
concerned about these broad statements
that are made without data
and I don't support that Amendment
representative black history
um I just uh I agree with what uh
representative Pearson said and I will
add that uh
um you know
prefer
none of the money on the state budget if
we're going to do it
all right representative fellows
um
I'm sorry I'm
just skip over me okay representative
O'Brien
yeah
thank you madam chair uh and with the
deepest of respect to my
fellow representative representative
Pearson uh with his bill I think by his
own admission what he has just said with
the school department is his entitled
opinion but let me Express mine when I
wrote uh House Bill 274
uh it was intended to give some form of
relief to municipalities at all every
single corner of the state from the
Canadian border down to the
Massachusetts border from the Atlantic
Ocean to the state of Vermont
now
the thing is if you have a particular
issue with your particular Community
that's why we have elections but I'd
much rather stay focused right on what
274 does
as we know we discussed before the state
used to pay 35 percent it was teared
down to zero since the 10 years it's
been teared down to zeros municipalities
had to face this burden of making up the
difference the structure of the nhrs and
the contribution rates didn't really
change that much the only thing the only
person that got a break was the state in
New Hampshire now I'm going to use
Nashua as the example and you can refer
this to your own particular communities
although nashua's numbers will probably
be bigger Manchester's may be a little
bit bigger than nashua's but they're all
comparatively the same
foreign
we have
180 police officers that are in the New
Hampshire Retirement System
uh we have 165 uh firefighters in the
New Hampshire retirement system and we
have
950 teachers now as we look at the
Pearson's Amendment the Pearson's
amendment is going to remove the
majority of the largest chair
out of this supposedly given the break
to attack to your constituents who pay
taxes
as in the example as we heard from the
mayor of Nashua
and that example
4.4 million dollars of taxpayers money
is going to the New Hampshire Retirement
System
so therefore let's look what is in the
example nashua's contribution rate the
police pay
338 uh
thousand uh dollars the fireplace 262
thousand dollars with the combination of
adding those numbers up of basically six
hundred thousand dollars the teacher
switches group one is six hundred and
forty eight thousand now you'll say geez
representative O'Brien you gave us
numbers that there was
950 teachers again that's the largest
group but let's keep in mind the
teachers only pay seven percent into the
New Hampshire retirement system police
and fire be in group two and that's why
the difference of group two and not to
be co-mingled or anything or confused
with group one uh basically pays
basically a little self of 13 12 point
something
now how's this affected uh this will
greatly affect like I say the city in
Nashua
it will affect your community Manchester
everybody else because basically the
Nashua tax rate as compared to everybody
else
you raise
the uh two million dollars seems to be
what raises the tax rate one percent now
if you should happen to live in a
community
where your individual town uh has
smaller than compared to Nashua you do
pay teachers in the New Hampshire
retirement system you might even have
police officers you may not have
165 offices in your community but you
may have a few you may have five so you
are paying
within the percentages because nobody
gets the break with into the New
Hampshire time system if you're
fortunate or unfortunate I would say
fortunate to have volunteer firefighters
then you're not paying anything into the
New Hampshire retirement system because
as in the volunteer status uh they don't
contribute to the New Hampshire
retirement system but again if you have
teachers and if you have police officers
you are making that contribution into
the uh New Hampshire retirement system
so based upon those numbers
I don't want you to follow down the
rabbit hole of
what 274 is supposed to do if you
believe like I do the intention of this
bill was to give a break to
municipalities
of the attacks burden into the New
Hampshire retirement system and we only
asked for five percent which was prudent
and judicial
keep in mind originally the state paid
the 35 percent so I feel when I authored
this bill I didn't come in high on a hog
with it I think I came in with a
reasonable dollar amount that would be
prudent and uh I want you to keep that
in mind as you consider the vote on this
that this was a prudent intent attempt
to alleviate the tax burden
that was downshifted to the
municipalities and thus got downshifted
into the uh the taxpayers of your
community so I urge you all to vote with
me to shoot down uh representative
Pearsons I think well-intentioned
Amendment
but to shoot that down let me see my
subsequent emotion could be made to
ought to pass on 274 Standalone I thank
you madam chair thank you thank you
representative
[Music]
I uh
thank you madam chair thank you
representative O'Brien I am uh I am a
student of the
of the history of the state pension
system that's something I've really
worked on myself if I had assurances
that this would provide tax relief
I would love this the problem is is that
historically and I can be from dairy and
being virtually a
outside of college pretty much a
lifelong resident of dairy the history
shows me otherwise that the taxpayers
will not see this
as a relief at all
and
so I embrace the concept of that and I I
applaud you for for recognizing
the situation
because it is a situation
I don't have a historical context within
my own Community to have that faith and
I'll give you an example since 1996 this
enrollment in the dairy school district
has gone down every year since 1996. we
have a thousand less students in k
through eight than we did 20 years ago
which would equate to around an 8
million dollar decrease in our budget
our School District budget is up 16
million dollars so I have no faith and
confidence whatsoever that this money is
going to be used for tax relief and I'm
and I it's I don't profess to know what
the other communities are specifically
doing but when I see things in the city
of Manchester where reports are coming
out telling them they need to mothball
High School in three elementary schools
and here we are with them not doing it
I just I'm seeing just too much of this
to lack the faith to go along with the
concept that that is the origin of this
representative Brian and uh again I
appreciate your angle on it I really do
and I do recognize it and I wish it was
true it's just in my mind it isn't
it
just wanted to ask representative
Pearson why he didn't instead of um
selecting only some of the
retiree one of the retiree regroups and
not the both of them why didn't he just
select both groups and use two percent
[Music]
because my my lack of confidence and the
ability to to have this actually help
the taxpayer is irrespective of a
percentage it is it is the philosophy to
which I have seen go forward for the
last 20 years so within this within
group especially the education wise so
you know where where the education gets
more attention in the state of New
Hampshire than anything else anything
else to the point where we have towns
that have sau's offices that have larger
budgets than their entire town
government
there is a line that needs to be drawn
and frankly I've had enough I just have
had enough
follow-up
follow up please
representative Pierce
son with the with the ex exception of
the two largest cities in the state it
has always absolutely always been the
case that the schools cost more than the
municipal side of the budget that's
that's just how it is there are far more
employees of cities and towns that work
for the school system it's just what the
job is representative fellas I don't
mean this the schools as a whole I'm
specifically referring to just the SAU
office of some of these towns have
massive budgets that that are rivaling
their own entire town budgets so I I get
the fact that the schools are up they're
obviously they're typically your Town's
largest employer and certainly from an
employee standpoint dwarf any other of
the Town side of things combined there's
no question for that it's just the we've
gotten to the point where just the
administration of schools has become so
grossly
inflated that and this isn't even
translating down to the classrooms so
I'm just I cannot
I cannot stomach just continuously
throwing money in here without seeing
some kind of results in some kind of
restraint on the part of these school
boards where I'm looking at Emergency
Services doing everything they can doing
less than most with more
so that's exactly what I meant
and and really taking taking the hits
and then when they save a nickel to
school spending the dime
I'm drawing the line I've just had it
and and I think that those that are
doing the right thing that are really
trying their best deserve to have some
sort of could be on the state's part to
to acknowledge that and those that are
not don't deserve it
and
one just one more comment
yes
um I I am quite amazed
that in a discussion about the state's
obligation to support the retirement
system
that this has devolved into a discussion
of SAU budgets that is really a huge
step stretch my imagination thank you
a lot of money in SIU budgets
representative Allegro well I I like
this amendment and I think it's a good
resolution to the impasse that we may
have reached and here's why
notwithstanding the idea that we're all
the same we are dealing with separate
entities here right we're dealing with
the school districts versus the
municipalities in our case you have one
group typing their belt and the other
group you have for continuation from
slicked spending
and where separate entities in another
sense as well I'm here representing
my constituents from Camden
not from Ashmore so I have to go back to
Canton
theoretically speaking and explain
to the constituents there to the
residents of Canton
why they're picking up the tab for the
profligated spending
in the National School District and so I
think that this distinction
allows us to bring relief to one entity
that has been tightening their belt as I
understand it
but
um
brings the reality of responsibility
to the to the other and who has not
so I'll be supporting this
yeah I mean the reason to bring in uh
yes are you uh spending on school
spending
is that under their spending and the
number of employees that hire has an
influence on what the country cost is
and therefore what the state's gonna
have to pay for it yet football we don't
have any direct control over that and uh
you know we have we're concerned that
that they're not being responsible in
that regard and therefore
um you know I'm not comfortable
um you know putting us on the hook for
further
in my view uncontrolled and
irresponsible
thank you representative Schultz and
representative Bryant you've already
spoken twice so I'm going to let people
vanished open speak before
thank you madam chair
um my question for representative
Pearson is
given that pensions are a promise
and given that that promise has been
made as well to local cities and towns
from the state
given that that promise is is also for
you as a firefighter isn't it perilous
to forego the
um Promises to the teachers too wouldn't
you want to As A Firefighter support all
public employees pensions that are
equally a promise
uh representative Schultz you're getting
very close to impugning his motives and
we don't allow that
let me see if I can rephrase it here's
what I I didn't mean to do that I see
what you're saying
um
and I will say that this this bill does
not affect
any benefits or pension
results or contributions by any employee
all it affects is who is paying the
state share
enough I the concern I have though is
when we start to parse this out
and we start to pick a part what has
been promised
it really does
pit groups against each other that
shouldn't be pitted against each other
is really what I'm trying to say whether
it's the promises we've made
to public employees who are public
servants who I feel are underpaid but
these promises should be met or the
taxpayers uh paying property taxes that
are struggling I hate to see any of our
Public Services of what we offer to our
communities also be thrown under the bus
and
I well I oppose this amendment because
of that
um
more time to debate just Steve and I
over lunch but it is as it is
so so to to to add a historical context
here because I did tell you that I am
really kind of Taken upon myself to be a
student of this if it really truly was
about
things rising and falling together the
pension changes in 2011 should have done
that and they did not
group two took a much bigger punch in
the face than group one did in the 2011
pension changes so we've already gone
down that road of looking at these two
groups separately and I I'm not I
completely
agree with your with your statement in
reference to public employees it's no
secret that I'm a big supporter of of
the employees themselves my sister was a
school teacher
in New Hampshire and my my brother's a
corrections officer so there's no
there's no love missing from my heart
for these people but this is this is a
deal that has to do with the in the
administrations of of these various
entities and just a
just at some point taking a stand and
that's and it's really just his like I
said before historically we're giving
them a dime and they're spending a
quarter in a that is just not
sustainable and I just don't have the
faith that this would equate to tax
relief and I wish I did
[Music]
um
questions appropriate but yeah okay yeah
debate in committee cannot be curtailed
questions representative thought now
uh thank you madam chair I guess I just
wanted to I'm I kind of missed the whole
connection here between uh House Bill
274 and and splitting the difference
between the group one and group two
um you know and not that I disagree at
all I've I've been at many City Council
meetings and and hollered and and whined
about property taxes and where's all the
money going and why are they spending it
on this and that and
Etc I don't disagree with the with
representative Pearson on on many of
those issues
however
um I don't think two this doesn't this
doesn't discern that at all whether you
if you take group one out of this bill
it doesn't
send less money to the uh to the school
department it it simply sends money less
money from the state back to the
municipality it doesn't it doesn't help
the firefighters it doesn't help the
policemen it doesn't hurt the teachers
it hurts the taxpayers plain and simple
it's it's all it's just one
it's one some group of money going to
the municipality and so I don't see I
think it would have made more sense if
you if you wanted to lower the amount of
money to lower the percentage but I
don't um I don't understand this uh this
separation uh in this particular bill
thank you symbolic
thank you madam chair
I am going to oppose the amendment I
think uh we heard from the missile
Association and many cities and towns
across the state looking for relief
and looking for a small fraction of the
promises that were made by the state of
New Hampshire uh and covering
parts of the costs of the cities and
towns towards the State retirement
system and taking one piece of that pie
away I cannot support it's
was group one and group two at the
beginning and it should go back to
remaining group one and group two when
the state gives their
percentage discount to the cities and
towns so I will vote against the
amendment thank you
thank you representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair uh there's a
couple of facts uh yeah if I just would
like to share with the committee
um
basically as many you know uh yeah I was
a firefighter for 35 years and you know
I am currently a member of the New
Hampshire retirement system and
receiving benefits so let's get that out
there but I am also besides the State
Rep I am also vice president of the
board of aldermen for the city of Nashua
I am on the budget committee and I am on
the finance committee and I think when
we get together we don't establish the
tax rate actually the state does is
established a tax rate but basically
when we work in in the budget and come
to find out what we basically do is we
try to run the city based upon the needs
now there was a statement that was made
that I can't guarantee that some of
these savings will go back well where
would they go is the question uh
anti-theoretically the way you run the
city at the end of the fiscal year yeah
you are fair in theory are not supposed
to be sitting on millions and millions
and millions of dollars the city is not
a bank
it's supposed to provide service to each
community so yes we do have a rainy day
account such as we had situations in the
past where a school Wall fell down and
needed to be repaired and stuff and yes
we did take that money out of our rainy
day account but basically when the
question gets asked where does the money
go it goes back into the community on
many of the things and one of the most
important things where will some of this
money go by a positive vote on 274
without this amendment in your
communities because I asked you to talk
to your city fathers
and your lead is on this and I hope that
you did but where would that money go it
will go back into your community by not
supporting this you might be doing
members of your community it's a service
you may be now there was also another
statement that uh oh I don't know if I
want to support Nashua with all this
well let me take you down the road of
percentages
Nashua doesn't pay more or doesn't pay
less than your community into the New
Hampshire Retirement System it pays the
percentage of basically what the
employee does so therefore to say one
Community gets a better deal than
another Community I think that's a very
fair question that the next time Mr
Colin comes up from nhrs that you can
ask him he'll tell you no uh
firefighters and police officers like I
say pay within the 12 percentile and
Teachers Pay within the seven percentile
that's true all across the board in the
whole state nobody is getting any
special benefits
so to say within what does money do
within the city budget maybe in your
community if you just please like I say
is the power of the the election box
maybe you can influence the budget but
basically what happens right now with
this
this has the backing of the New
Hampshire Municipal Association as
representative goalie said and the
reason they support it it is a car
across the board attempt
to alleviate
the tax the burden on the taxpayers and
that's why I wrote 274 and
unfortunately with deepest respect to
representative Pearson it would
partially dismantle that because by just
with the volume of group two people
alone
you would be taking down basically a
half a percent or something like that
that would benefit the taxpayers thank
you madam chair
representative Allegra no I'm forced to
respond to that I don't remember hearing
anybody uh say the things that you
quoted being said there certainly I can
speak for myself I didn't say that but I
will say this you're absolutely right
the city is not a bank
so there should be not there should not
be millions and millions and millions of
dollars in Surplus neither should there
dollars in debt
now
I didn't say that one Community gets
more or benefits more from the other
but I'll tell you what I did say I don't
remember my exact words but I'll use the
same sentiment certainly some
communities waste more
and going back to my community and
telling them that they have to pay for
the waste in communities that waste more
than us and mind you aren't you my
district My Town my community
waste plenty of money I mean that's the
problem and that goes right to the heart
of Representative Pearson's assertion
here is that
if we reward waste by coming in
constantly and giving a quarter for
every organ yeah having a quarter
request before every time that we offer
and then paying it
the waste never ends
and uh
I know I had one other thing to say but
uh the hour is getting late and uh I'll
just leave it at that thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
need to speak
okay see none the motion is to adopt
amendment 0295 to House Bill 591 house
bill 274.
A.M
representative Warner yes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative
yes representative yes representative
Allegro yes representative Bailey yes
representative and Sarah
yes
representative senator nastasso
yes representative goalie
no
representative
no representative Judy
no
representative Schmidt
no representative Schultz no
representative fellows no
representative
no
representative wrote it no
representative O'Brien
no here
yes
representative Pearson do you have a
motion color s
note by representative Pearson
seconded by representative Allegro
you should speak to your doctor
Al uh
no I think it's all good
one else who wishes to speak on the
motion about to pass
with this amendment
seeing none in that case
but the passes amended representative
Werner
is
yes representative Pearson yes
representative yakubovic
no
Representative blackis no
representative Allegro
sorry I'm confused we're voting on on
Japan
yes
representative Bailey
representative Lazaro
yes
representative
no
representative goalie
representative
no
representative Judy
representative Schmidt
no
representative Schultz
uh representative fellows
no
representative
representative wrote it
no representative O'Brien
no
uh and the chair
yes
seven in the affirmative twelve in the
negative
the motion fails what the past cemented
fails
we move on to pass with Amendment
representative Schultz moves on to pass
without Amendment
not too fast purely but not the
amendment oh second
I really feel like he should be doing
the first one increase
[Music]
that motion before
this is ought to pass uh representative
Schultz you made the emotion yes she did
and the second was
representative O'Brien Ryan yes thank
you
is there anything to be said that wasn't
already said
I don't think so I think we've been
pretty articulate today huh
I agree Madam chair thank you all right
motion is thought to pass
on House Bill 274.
I representative representative Werner
no
clerklets no representative Pearson you
know representative yakovich
no
Representatives like this no
representative Allegro no representative
Bailey no representative lazara
no representative
no
representative goalie
yes
representative show it yes
representative Judy
representative Schmidt
yes Schultz
yes representative fellows
yes representative Fontenot yes
representative Rhoda yes
representative O'Brien
yes and the chair
no
uh 9 10.
I moved
it is our second second if I
representative
I'll start it if you like thank you
madam chair
obviously obviously we can't find
something to ground well
well itl
well let's try that yeah
right
so what happens if the retain fits
um
made
yes representative Schmidt the motion
was made representative goalie
that's okay do you want I'll let you
speak to your motion first then I'd like
to speak on this motion
okay
um
we have not been able to agree on itl
ought to pass or ought to pass with an
amendment no one else has brought
forward any other Amendment
we're at our deadline and
this is something that we are divided on
but it is important and I think we
should retain it
for example please
thank you madam chair I will be voting
against retaining uh this isn't the only
other option we have we have the option
of sending it to the floor without
recommendation if this motion shall fail
um
this is the budget year this is when
this should be being taken up the cities
and towns are looking for Relief and
this is a way of providing that relief
this is scheduled to go to the second
hearing uh so that it would be the
numbers can be figured out and it can be
part of
um if passed uh can be included within
the budget if we retain it it does no
good the budget will be done the money
won't be there so I don't see a reason
to retain this I think we should vote on
it act on it today and if we have to
send it to the floor without
recommendation and let the whole house
fall behind thank you unless someone
wants to step up we can't send it
without recommendation is that an odd
number wrong sorry
but uh anyone else
well I would I would also like to
mention that the Senate has a similar
bill that includes a contribution to
retirement system you are working on it
I believe I don't know whether just pass
the senate or not I do know it is being
considered there
point-of-point order bouncer yeah oh I'm
sorry go ahead representative point of
order I believe if no
motion comes out of this
committee with a positive vote then it
goes to the floor without recommendation
is my recollection
so if this goes down and we've made all
of the attempts on the motions and
nothing passes that is when it goes to
the floor it doesn't go on a tie vote it
goes on I
thank you that's a good point I hadn't
thought of it
thank you darling is that the case can
we vote to give it with no
recommendation
yes if every motion fails you're you're
left with
no recommendation
okay in that case I will withdraw my
motion to retain
and
entertain representative Foley's motion
to send it with no recommendation I
second
actually what about that or just do
nothing
you madam chair yes
if I may
um and Pam correct me if I'm wrong I I'm
not even sure if retain has to be taken
up as long as we take up the itl the
amendments in the ought to pass to send
it on without recommendation Pam could
you correct me if I'm wrong well I could
I could give Paul Smith a call if you
like to be to be 100 sure I'm not sure
about that
well we definitely ought not to
hypothesize let's find out from the
clerk
I've got his uh cell phone I'll I'll be
back to you Logan well we it won't hurt
to vote on no recommendation there
manager if I may there is no vote on a
on that motion it's just if all the
votes fail then that's the way the
committee sends it there is no way to
vote
you cannot send something by a positive
[Music]
if I if I'm clear on that I would agree
with representative goalie I believe the
clerk is going to state that uh without
recommendation is technically not
emotional we would vote on
yeah that's how it was with indigenous
people's day about a year or two ago
our emotions weren't working then either
while we're waiting I just want to
commend you for making this through this
this very complicated and
um
let me see how I can use it and a topic
that has great difference of opinion and
I I feel as if I've certainly been heard
and I just want you to know that I
appreciate
um the work and your sentiment during
this bill the voting of this Bill thank
you
Madam chair if I beg
yes please no wait and I just want to
say uh how much uh that I did enjoy the
debate on this particular bill I thank
you for listening to me being a new
member of the committee and uh
unfortunately we have all our opinions
and of course I respect that but I I did
enjoy and I thought there was a a very
well thought of discussion on both sides
of the issue wanted and I thank you all
for that thank you
it's something that we we agree on no
recommendation representative O'Brien
would you care to write the
recommendation of what to pass
thank you madam chair I would all right
I will write a recommendation in favor
of an expedient to legislate and mention
the amendment that was adopted but not
uh
not included
uh when does it uh needed I'm kind of
working on my first novel
okay
I assume this can't be enough
if it needs to novel it can be a novel
I would I would say that a short story
is probably the maximum most people no
no excuse me Madam chair I met what is
the date that you would like it by
Monday
um okay thank you
it will be novel though
that's too much like the novel
coronavirus yeah let's not go there
representative scitec please speaking of
novels I'm thinking of uh mobile dick
where he should have left whale on us
alone
but I'm going to here is some heresy for
another day I like the property tax
and I would I like to defend that
position sometime
I've also heard you say you like the
sales tax too if that if it comes to it
Madam chairman I I tried calling the
house clerk on his cell phone and got
his voicemail so I did not have success
there but I well with representative
goalie's experience as a former chair
and say we will put it out with no
recommendation and have to argue
arguments in favor of people to pass
it sounds so beautiful to me for what
it's worth no it's none of the Motions
passed a delightful day in the
neighborhood
[Music]
Monday is a holiday and a day off for
everyone who has their boards in
uh
we are meeting on Thursday for the
continued hearings for these bills
for morning bills
and we are then the following Monday on
the last of our original most of them
all the special days and a few other
bills
and am I starting at 9 30 or 10 on the
18th
and
thank you
right
thank you all again we are adjourned
thank you and I'll buy the first press
have a safe ride home everybody
[Music]
let's go downstairs and uh and climb my
life amazingly education on hb20 get out
early yeah a lot of people have signed
up to talk
that second day and the uh I assume the
video and the audio are off now no
sorry